...
That voice crack!
Good morning!
Good afternoon!
I can't remember what I was saying.
You cannot hear background game audio because it's...
You need to be inside the thing.
Hold it together, friend.
If it's for friends who did stuff together,
you're so you love me.
And it's for anytime, anywhere at all.
Done in the deep blue sea.
Bum, bum, bum.
Mama, we've won!
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon!
Nice hat!
What are you talking about hat?
I am a real hedgehog.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
Hat?
Nonsense.
I've never seen such acts of...
Lies.
Yeah, then did I have a good wake up?
Uh...
Look, I don't know how to say this hair.
I woke up saying Shivi's ass.
I'm like, God, fucking damn!
Don't mind if I do.
So Shivi may or may not be dropping your pictures soon.
Sorry if I spoiled it.
My fault is Shivi.
I like...
So when I wake up, you know, I've got a few DMs.
Like, there is like, yep, Donutons are good to go.
So, you know, I'm going to message the girls and say, you know,
some of yous are a part of the...
Everyone's a part of the Donuton in some way.
And we'll extend that help to each other.
Amy's going to check over a file.
But she handed me over these files that are perfect.
And she's getting a few more shots coming through.
Lovely, jubbly.
Amy's been cheating.
It shouldn't need anything at the moment.
And...
Oh, that jazz.
And then Shivi's like...
Can I send you my ass pic?
I'm like, mmm!
I'm like, good morning!
Good morning!
Like, fuck it, like Hallelu.
Like, what? Yes?
I mean, no, yeah, no, that's fine.
No, that's fine.
Have you seen her tweet about you?
Oh, Monka fucking is?
Holy crap.
The other crumbling from the inside out.
Monka is?
Monka is where?
On her main or on her alt?
Someone asked, are you doing the Black Ops 1 campaign
on veteran mode or not?
My guy, you've watched enough of me!
On her alt?
Monka, Shivi, Cotton, Mom.
Oh, wait, no, that's the word.
It's called check.
Shivi knows my for work.
I'm scared.
What did she say about me?
Oh, no!
She's shit!
She exposed my tweet!
Oh, no, that is me!
I literally woke up
by 30 minutes ago.
Absolute veteran recruit.
Yep, recruit.
I mean, we're recruiting these veterans
because we're just so good together.
It's running as a brilliant aspect.
Oh, my God.
I like it, I like it.
I'm bookmarking that OC she posted below the tweet.
Totally not using that.
Is there anything I missed?
Is everything blown up?
Or is everything good?
No, everything looks,
it all looks good to me.
Time to open up marshmallows.
I've got a cup of tea,
but good morning, reflans.
I hope you're okay.
Sleep check, I got
five dollars.
But to add to that,
I passed out after stream yesterday.
And then I've reviewed six audios so far.
I think I have three more audios to review.
And then Patreon's going to get nine early access uploads.
But then, like, every other day,
YouTube is going to get a milestone upload.
Although there's two audios I'm unsure about.
I don't know how much you guys are in the ASMR world.
Three separate VTuber
slash roleplay creators received warnings.
One person got it for kissing.
One person got it for towel rubbing.
They time stamped it.
It was like an Emmy situation where it was like,
I don't know what your AI is doing,
but that's a towel.
And it's very clearly a towel.
And the third one was just a roleplay
that didn't come with a time stamp.
It just got like, there's something scary going on about YouTube.
I had a bit of a discussion with the girls.
Obviously, for them who don't have a warning,
it's okay to kind of push the envelope a wee bit.
But for, you know,
those who really want to hone in on being safe,
I'm not forcing them to like roleplay ASMR, any of that stuff.
It seems like what's actually safer now
is full on roleplay videos instead of live streams.
Live streams and the AI that kind of farts through them
seems to be going absolutely mental
because I think when a user put it or someone put it
and it was basically like, yeah,
you're going to need to update the AI
so it knows the difference between a human breath and oxygen
and like trying to make popcorn, basically.
And the thing is, they've not publicly...
I'll keep hammering home about this.
I don't care.
Johnny, just get over it.
No, one, that's an all right video game.
Everyone seems to be addicted to that too.
They've not publicly...
So YouTube will notify you
if there's upcoming policy changes for you, the creator,
especially if you're on the program
because you like have access to help and all that.
Well, a bit more help than the average Joe,
but you still have to go to Twitter to beg the review team
because the review team and the YouTube help team
aren't the same team.
It's ridiculous.
Absolutely ridiculous.
So, I basically...
I don't know what's going to happen with the live stream.
So live stream ASMR is still on the table for viewer.
No problems.
I think for those of us with a warning right now,
it's like, bro, what do you want from us?
Seriously.
Yo, what's good?
No, it's getting scary.
My friend lost her ASMR channel.
I'm not even surprised with the rate
that I see a new thing pop up and a new thing get.
Imagine having to go to another platform
to ask for help on their platform.
Yes, that is a fundamental issue, which is terrible.
Right, okay.
Someone says, I feel like trauma dumping.
Trauma dump.
Here goes.
Can I kiss you, mummy?
Hi, mummy.
I jerked my pentas to your audio yesterday
when a question popped up in my head.
Oh, were you a bit distracted with your inner thoughts?
When did you realize that you were a banal slut?
Thanks.
I love you, strong.
I love you too.
What a question.
First thing in the morning.
Good morning to you.
Talk to the morning to you, laddie.
My name is Stony Cuddles.
Hi.
When did I realize I liked...
So when I was a young little cuttlefish,
I discovered very...
Oh, this sounds really bad.
Hold on.
Let me put the Sonic Heroes theme in the background
whilst I explain the story.
Okay.
If there is...
There we go.
Okay, that's what we need to really top off this background.
I discovered very quickly
that I could only fit a singular.
And then I was like,
well, this hole isn't working.
I want to try another one.
And then I was like,
huh, that was a lot nicer.
It's basically how it went.
Go away, away.
Sonic Heroes.
Only logical leap.
Write that down, Stony.
I've got the basic...
Oh, no, I talk about it,
because I don't want...
Like, you never know.
Someone might be listening in
that actually has the same issues.
And there is, unironically,
something called tight clam syndrome,
so I don't mind talking about it.
I think that's what our boss is, by the way,
when we 100% the game.
I'm not sure, but I think so.
Hello, Strony.
I'm wondering now that all the girls
have a blue site,
if they are updated regularly,
Veilure and blue site,
there is one, no contractual obligations.
Whatever the girls do on that website is theirs.
They are responsible for it.
The contract stipulates
we ask for four audios per month
and three streams per week barring anything.
If anything is to occur in a girl's personal life,
we couldn't give less of a shit about the contract.
They can wipe their arse with it,
because that's what humans do to each other.
They are nice to each other.
As for anything that does occur on the blue site,
nothing to do with me.
It's completely independent
of anything that we dictate.
It's whatever the girls come to be with,
whatever she wants to charge,
whatever she wants to earn,
we don't touch that.
We don't touch that, okay?
Okay.
Amy was playing this yesterday
and I'm like, yes, give me the notes.
Wait, it takes twenty-eight hours for a hundred percent?
No, it doesn't.
It takes three hours per team.
Are you trolling me?
Don't you be trolling me?
It takes three hours per team, does it not?
There's an extra mission for all four teams.
That takes, what, ten hours?
How much did that fresh Sonic the Hero save file
set you back?
And I won!
How many teams are there?
So we're about to finish the second team.
We're right before it.
The game sound is a little low.
Okay.
Just a note.
How's that for game sound over me?
I also skipped the Emerald missions.
I couldn't gear.
Respectfully.
Um...
Hee-hee.
Right, everything looks good.
Looks like nothing blew up overnight.
Azura's mock of her donut-thon has been made.
Like, the little...
this thing that gets posted.
What's Amy tweeting about?
She says,
Amy says,
Don't tell my college,
but I'm secretly still using my student card
for the City Boss even though I graduated,
because it works.
Please, let them forget to deactivate.
We learn too.
I am the ultimate consumer.
Big corporations love me.
Amazon love me.
Google love me.
Samsung love me.
I consume everything they advertise to me.
I graciously denate my entire paycheck.
What the fuck is Amy even on about?
What are you spouting about?
Imma give it a like anyway,
but seriously,
what are you spouting about?
What are you on about, Lisa?
What's going on?
Oh, Azura posted her cover-up toggle.
Imma post the link in chat.
Let me see that.
So, Shibi and Azura getting tasteful cover-up toggles.
They're nothing extreme.
They're tasteful cover-up toggles.
Just so YouTube can relax.
And I thought this was perfect for Azura.
Are you squinting me right now?
Oh, god, the name.
Maybe you want to use Sonic music for the Lyobi GMs.
If you want the honest,
like, actuals just straight up honest answer.
Very selfish autism.
No.
Thank you, groomed by Vila for this super chat.
If you want me to say a PR answer,
I will say that,
Sonic Heroes has a fantastic diversity of background music
and shows the love and care that-
that- that- that-
get it?
So, are you obsessed with Sonic 2?
Only Sonic Heroes is the game.
I tried to play Sonic Unleashed,
but I was so young that I couldn't figure out what I had to do.
Now, if you've ever played Sonic Unleashed,
there's-
the first, like, battle dome you get put in
is, like, a French palazzo,
and I get stuck in it,
and I've never gone further.
I did do Sonic Rush on the DS.
We might actually play that,
because I've got a few DS games planned.
I have Professor Layton in the Curious Village.
Yes, you're carrying me through the puzzles,
because I can't figure them out.
And then you're gonna-
we're gonna play Dragon Quest then,
and why is everyone laughing at my name?
I mean, is there a laughter-
You called yourself groomed by Vila!
Yeah, look!
Brian, don't read that out!
He better not read that out.
How are we supposed to respond?
Bro, you've got tons of questions.
I have a very big job today,
which is give the thumbs up for the last of those audios,
and I also am going to send away a bajillion clips.
So thank you again to everyone who clips me.
I am about to send a ridiculous amount of clips away,
so thank you for everyone who's done it.
That's my job today,
is to finalize my thingy-ma-bobber.
My audios are early access,
and then go through all my clips,
which I've got quite a lot to go through.
Yeah, Dragon Quest 9.
That's right.
We're playing Dragon Quest 9 Sentinels of the Stars, guys,
and yes, I'm a voice actor through that damn thing,
because literally one of the first bosses you go against
is Scottish!
It's randomly Scottish and slang-worthy, okay?
Shadow the Hedgehog is just Sonic with guns.
I'm not sorry.
Look, you're not wrong, the Booty Lord.
You're not wrong.
Thank you for this super shit, Mummy.
I hope you play Sonic Unleashed at some point.
It is a great game.
Once I found out what to do,
I was stuck too.
Why was it so hard?
Sentinels.
Is that on what it's called?
Dragon Quest Sentinels of the Stars, guys.
The Sonic here makes the Sonic just trying to eat your head.
What are you talking about?
This is my real hair.
Look, I didn't have time to make myself bald.
Hello, glad I was able to make this stream.
Right, let us take a gander at my save file.
Right, so my save file.
We have completed Sonic's team.
We're going to complete Chaos's team.
We're maybe an hour off of Chaos,
and then we'll spam Team Rose,
because I already know Team Rose at the back of my hand.
But the problem is Team Dark.
I've never played Team Dark,
because I was scared of Team Dark,
because they were the bad team.
They were the evil team,
but they're not really evil.
They're just misunderstood, okay?
Team Rose is free eats.
As you prepare, yes.
Team Dark's missions are very long.
Team Dark is just on it.
I don't know if you could just fly past all the enemies.
You'll even run through Team Rose.
Yeah, I think people said 100%,
it takes 20 hours.
I feel not the final boss left though.
Oh, like if you want all the Emerald Roses.
So, I'm naughty,
and I purposefully avoid the...
Oh god, where are we?
The Castello.
Oh my god, I forgot I love to be.
Nothing new for you, Vector.
Hmm?
What is it?
Uh-huh.
Okay.
It's the find money.
But yeah.
I see where you are.
Okay, let's get to it.
Do tell me how you find...
I too think there's a key around here.
Oh shit.
Can those pumpkins hurt me?
I have no idea.
Ah.
Here we go.
Oh my god, this is so cute.
Oh no, I'm not good at this.
I didn't know if I was supposed to jump, I did anyway.
And the camera angle stuck to a right angle.
I can't see it.
See ya.
But yes, as that refling...
Wait, what?
As that refling said, all the girls' background music
are based after this video game.
I have a very big master debate
about what to base Gen 2.
Where are we?
Hello?
Oh.
Have a very big master debate
about what I should do
for Gen 2.
Sorry.
Okay.
Sorry, I'm hesitating so much.
Woo!
Okay.
Use Sonic.
I would pick a different game genre.
Nice hat.
Probs not Halo.
No, I wouldn't pick Halo.
I have been debating about Legend of Zelda Minish Tap,
but the problem is it's 8-bit music.
I don't know if that's a problem.
Um...
Wait, what?
How do I get him?
He's golden!
Ah, okay, he's not invincible though.
The upside down and right side up maps
are actually completely separate from each other.
They're not the same map flip.
That's why the screen goes white when you switch.
Oh, it's to hide it!
Oh, I feel like there's a key down here.
Sorry, I knew it.
I saw it!
Wait, I saw it!
There's like a red thing.
Let me in!
I saw it.
You can see a little red box down there.
Maybe we unlock it next, I guess.
Can I go up the rail?
I can!
Is there like a hidden key in here?
Key? Key? Hidden key? Hello?
Yes!
Okay, we're actually so good at this game.
Why specifically Minish Cap?
It's the only legendary lunk I've played.
And it just means a lot.
It's just a really well-rounded game.
It's just...
Oh, sorry, I should have put that on.
Charming key!
We're only halfway there.
Sorry, we're rolling and smoking this one.
Come on.
I can't.
These guys are...
The crocodile bee in the pink one, I think, is a rhino.
Sorry.
Call me Mercy Modus cause platforming hard.
Okay, a little cheeky fight.
Don't mind us.
Did you hear that?
They're like, if you stay, stay quiet.
Me who comes in.
Chameleon.
Oh, close enough.
That's a chameleon.
I hope the Mario's there and ends with a happy Strony.
I'll read Mario's at the end of the PlayStation.
The PlayStation!
Why is the platform like that?
Oh, I don't trust this.
Oh, that's Espeon's poles?
Oh, I'm not...
No.
I...
Unless...
There appears to be something in the render distance.
I'm not risking Espeon poles.
I don't think that's...
I'm going back.
Sorry, I'm turning back.
I'm scared.
If I can't even get on the dang thing.
Put me on the other side.
I think there was something here.
No, don't.
You're too quick.
Oh, wait.
Espeon's leveled up enough that a...
Wait, I thought if I was level three, I could demolish stuff.
No, we're going to get caught.
So, we're going to get...
Oh, my God.
Stay plain.
We're going to get stopped.
We're going to get caught.
I'm just...
I was going to say, was that supposed to go...
I'm flying all the way.
I didn't know you ran out of fly like that and you just dropped.
Are you not Bumblebee?
What's going on?
Dumbass.
Wait, how is that supposed to get all the way over there?
And I've lost my wee level up.
What was that supposed to do?
Espeon pinball that shit?
What, then quickly go to the Bumblebee?
Oh, for fuck's sake!
I'm losing the IQ test here.
Was there something down there?
Some sort of pile.
I will make my own way.
Fine.
If you keep killing me at one specific point,
I'm going to make my own way in this game.
You want to share the same brain cell to the refunds users?
I think I might need to borrow it slightly today.
I'm not going to lie.
I thought this was going to be easy peasy.
As I said, I like playing child games because it's like,
I don't have to sweat that much.
Well, I missed everything there.
But I have, wait.
No.
No?
I've just done a big massive circle.
Is this?
What?
I'm so turned around right now.
I think I've just done a massive circle by accident.
Oh, that doesn't even hurt them because of their armor.
As if that hit my forehead!
Hold on.
God, he's got armor as well.
Oh, jeez.
Right.
It says fly.
So if I hit that pinball thing,
is that going to spank me a bit ahead?
Surely that's how it works.
No, I'm just dumb and I didn't wait for the platform length.
I really do be making my...
Do be making things harder than this thing.
What did that do?
Speak up.
Why have I got a little...
He can transform himself when flipped over.
What?
So beat him up now.
I'm burping.
No.
Okay, right.
I'm happy with that.
Okay.
It's not that bad.
Relax.
Okay.
I suck a little bit, but not that bad.
Oh, it's Sonic time.
Oh, yeah.
And Sonic's all over you.
I assume those guys can...
You cheats.
I literally...
Oh, what?
I'm so confused.
I need to do it in between the flames.
I hate render distance IQ.
I'm trying.
Easy.
Gorgeous.
Stunning.
Get me the fuck on the other side of this.
I'm no having it.
Okay.
We're doing it.
We're doing it again.
Well, if I'm struggling with this team,
I'm not sure Shadow's team is going to be that easy.
Where is that?
Who wants me here?
Hello?
Did I not pull this all the way out?
Where is it?
I don't see it.
Normally, they have it against the wall.
What do you see?
I did.
Let me in.
There's a crack in the wall.
Wait.
No.
How did you see that?
Oh, my God.
Thank God you're here.
I would have been like,
well, then during streams over,
let's play some vermin tide boys.
I'm so excited to play vermin tide again.
I do like the paralysis.
Tomorrow, we're going to do the full vermin tide.
During the members script writing,
we're going to...
We're going to...
Sorry, I can't seem to play.
I thought this game would be a bit easier,
but I'm struggling to get through this something.
We're going to be writing collab scripts
because I have a lot of VTubers that were very kind
and have been nothing but patient
when it comes to collab scripts,
but I've taken my sweet time.
I am going to basically say to them,
I'm going to basically try and finish up
what scripts I need to do.
No, this game is hard.
Don't worry.
It's the physics.
Like, whatever I do, real path.
I have no idea if I've gone too far.
Are you serious?
Is this one of them ones where it's like,
oh, you have to...
Oh, no, it's just a switch on the door.
I thought it was going to be like,
go back down to the bottom and deal with everything
and I'm like, no, I don't want to.
Vermintide is StreamSnipe.
Yes, it's the StreamSnipe game.
Also, Reeflands, you're in trouble.
Someone gifted me StreamSnipe games
on that Steam account.
Reeflands, you do not have to gift me games on that.
I understand.
That was very kind of you.
It was games like Deep Rock Galactica.
Oh, no, am I back at the start?
No!
Oh, no.
I'm back at the start.
That means I've missed keys.
Because they put more than one down.
Yes, someone gave me the...
But no, you don't have to buy games
that you'd like to play together.
I'll pay for it.
Don't you?
Let's go down there.
Do you want to see how...
I hear he's strutting.
They better not.
Are those Eggman's robots?
Sometimes.
Oh, right.
Let's just give it a go.
Oh, no!
I think the SB on Tolls is probably next.
Can I stay on this one?
Oh, I can.
Oh, I jumped off thinking it was a dead end.
I can't believe it.
I'm actually going to have to look for the keys.
She's our sugar mummy.
She's the one that buys the games.
I don't...
I feel a bit strange, like...
I feel like if you buy video games for me,
that's like paying to see the content
that I'm already providing.
Which, like, my brain came to short circuits.
It's like,
but wait, that's not how it should work.
Like, Lance, what are you talking about?
You know?
We're on air.
For a second there,
I thought the refling bleeps some info.
You told us some confidence, little boy.
That's my voice.
Let's just guess.
Let's just...
My violent little refling.
Thank you, the very Lord.
No, you guys don't actually get in trouble.
You can't do anything bad in my head.
Please, camera angle.
It's implying there's something over here,
but I can't see because of the way
the camera angle works in this game.
I'm going to have to use this flower.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Let's stop.
Okay, that was lucky that we could get out of that situation.
Look, the door's open.
Now, we're purposely avoiding those keys
because they are really annoying.
I don't want to deal with them.
Right, do we even need to say...
I don't know how I get past these.
There's something behind here.
I don't know how to get it.
I don't know.
There's definitely something behind these things.
Can't you just decline gifting games?
Yes, I didn't accept them.
Because I'm all about the respect.
Right, no, I don't need...
They already got the key that was up there.
I just need...
Right, so I went down there
and it took me to where I'm about to go.
Wait, shit.
The camera doesn't follow.
It refuses to follow me.
Oh!
Oh, well.
When you put it like that...
Wait, what?
It's not doing it anymore.
What?
Why did it do it and then it stopped?
No, give it back.
Wait, did I come from that flower?
I can't remember.
Oh, please, I'm dying.
Please, just stand on the flower.
Please, oh, wait.
Stop!
It like blocks me from going on it a little bit.
So then I go like too far.
Right, and then...
Okay, this is definitely...
Okay, no, fuck him up.
Right, this is clearly where one of them are.
Can Espeon really jump that far?
Like, that seems...
Um...
Like, that looks crazy for a jump for Espeon.
But they're definitely key on the other side.
I think this part is Dark Sonic only.
He can.
Oh, wait.
I come back as Dark Sonic to play maps for other characters.
Is an Espeon a Pokemon?
I'm not saying his name wrong.
Ehehe, I'm such a big gamer.
Remember, for everyone that's listening right now,
I play video games for male attention.
I actually don't like video games at all.
And something, something mildly believable.
Right, okay, now that I have camera ability,
I'm checking my peripherals.
Okay, we're just gonna hover.
Oh, great, we can't see it.
That was very lucky.
I love my pick-me-wife!
Oh my god.
You forgot to say the streams are pre-recorded.
Oh yeah, and the streams are pre-recorded.
I'm not actually here.
I don't...
want to set the world on fire.
Okay, progress, progress.
So then where's the 10th one?
Normally, the beam powder and like everything
I need to find around the map.
But I've been getting nearer.
Right, a little to the right.
I'll hit video game.
Are you...
No.
Denny, Denny start up now.
Denny actual start up now.
Denny, you're annoying me.
You're gonna make me fart in anger.
Stop it.
Right, is there a hidden key as soon as you enter?
No.
Wait, is there a broken wall maybe?
And they've hidden it behind a broken wall.
Where is my check?
You owe me four weeks of pay.
Pre-recorded pay.
There's a broken wall!
Oh my god, I'm so smart.
I was like, nah, they've hidden it behind something.
I'm so smart.
Why do I have two DMs on this card?
Stop it.
It's turning me on.
I can't eat it.
Sorry, I'm getting a music video for Emmy.
I have been having an issue so badly trying to get...
E!
I tried my best.
Yeah, so I'm getting a music video for Emmy,
but there's one version is for shorts,
and one version is for video.
Like a regular, schmedular video.
Extinguish the red torch.
How do I do that?
Like this?
Oh my god, it's in the room.
It is for...
Oh my god, exactly.
Actually, I'm sure.
So I guess the blue doesn't do anything?
Oh no, the blue...
Well, the blue doesn't count.
It looks like it's red torches only.
I see where you are!
I love the way he says that.
Here we go.
What am I supposed to do with that?
It just starts flipping in the sky.
What do I do with that?
I just spin in.
I'm so excited.
Shoot it when you're far away.
Oh, the spin makes it invincible?
Oh, that's it.
Alright.
Aw, I like this curvy shield.
It doesn't mess up.
Okay.
Svm got level up.
Is there a secret red?
Oh my god, we can rotate!
Oh my god, I'm so good at rotating.
I'm so good at this game, sorry.
I know you didn't expect to know
that there's a Sonic Heroes veteran right now,
but I don't know what to say, baby.
I don't know what to say.
We're not opening the key because
it's not time to come out of Chastity yet.
Sorry, there was like
nothing put behind that.
I apologize.
Please forgive.
Okay, there's not like a secret one.
We have to do 50?
50 more?
Bobel means we're protected for our next injury.
Right, no secret.
Oh no, too many enemies.
What happens if I sing to them?
I would not trust me with that shit.
That stuff ain't coming back.
Bro, you don't need to buy one of them.
Like those things that the chain locks open?
Like the big massive like flyer,
like the huge mungus flyer thing.
You know what I'm on about?
Because there's no way that key's coming back.
I'll be like, uh, who sent it?
Bullcars!
Oh, no way.
I just used my ultimate.
Are you serious?
You sent something.
Is it maybe the big massive enemy?
We did not do an espion.
We're still in a wee fight.
Oh no, you're not espion.
You're the wee bee.
Can I just bonk his head?
I think I can just bonk his head.
I'll literally say bonk.
Oh, I like that.
Bonk, bonk.
I would like to level up.
I'm thinking Bobelber, what's this?
Is there any secrets?
Oh my god, I'm getting encouragement.
He said you keep going.
Stop it, Mr. Ghost.
You're scaring me.
The background music is six different
16 seconds long loops,
and it sequels seamlessly,
depending on the part of the stage you're in.
And laggy?
My swim?
Let's get rid of him first before we...
And then...
We're on 18 now.
Total.
Which is good.
And there's nothing hidden behind me.
Isn't there a lot in Order SBU episode
about Gamers starring Logan Paul?
What?
What is that?
I guess it's just for decoration.
There's what again?
Right, I don't see a heavy one.
Yay, it's finally based on a game.
I don't care what anyone says.
Wait, I messed up.
Hold on, we gotta go bold.
We gotta go bold, I messed up.
Okay, that looks doable.
Oh my god, please, Mr. Skeleton.
Give her breast already.
Okay, I'll get in.
Why is there an upside down?
Why'd I have to make a choice?
Oh wow, okay.
How many's here?
Did I get that one?
Right, we're on 20, so we're one third of the way there.
22...
23...
24...
25...
I'll happily go around and around and around, are you joking?
I'm getting all these for free!
We're getting like, what, 10 here?
20...
Yeah, we literally just went in the circle.
That was good, how was that bad?
So I can't go like, in these things in particular.
No, okay, it doesn't like that, okay.
Where's that flower to put me back?
Okay, this was just got 10 inside, so now we're halfway there.
We're halfway there.
Oh, I want to do a drop of Tariel pieces.
I think I'll be doing it around...
Wait, what?
Oh sorry, I got a little scared there.
No, no, go the other way.
No, all the way.
Huh, what?
Huh?
I think I maybe just need to kill the monster guy again.
I'm confused...
Not to be confused with.
Okay, right, I just had to kind of reset, I guess.
The target?
The target in the endless hallway.
Okay, right, okay, there's a target switch in the endless hallway.
No, what are you doing?
Okay, let's...
Okay, okay, there's a switch in the hallway.
Can I make it over?
I think I can.
Okay, switch in the hallway.
I didn't see the switch.
I'm sorry, thank you for telling me though.
We love streams that we love backseat gaming in this house!
I stand backseat gaming!
I don't care what anyone says, it's the best thing ever.
What do you mean I look like I'm MLG at every game I play?
Backseat me!
Right, there's a switch in the endless hallway.
A switch.
My eyeballs are open.
We're up!
Must be up, right?
That's not a switch.
No, that's just money.
I heard that!
I heard it!
Okay, never mind, where are we?
There's like, tons more!
Is there anything behind me?
No.
Is that even...
You got absolutely destroyed, I was invisible.
Okay, we're at 34?
How do I jump off?
Oh, close enough!
I'm really glad the game didn't kill me there.
Oh wait, hold on, I need to become the crocodile, hold on.
Wee!
Wait, oh no, not another IQ test!
Please, I can't handle any more IQ.
Oh, here it is, I see it, I see it, I see it, cracked wall.
They are so sneaky about that, sorry, but there's no wonder I got stuck as a wane in the game.
They are sneaky sneakertons.
Uh...
It's up here.
Yes!
Oh no.
Ooh, I saw the bottom of the map.
That's gonna be a fight, clearly.
Thankfully, I have my ultimate, geez, why are they trying to jump scare you?
That is the most...
Sonic has got a baby game, this is serious, exactly.
Look, I'm here to try hard.
Old games are filled to the brim with old walls.
Fake walls, sorry, not old walls.
You know what else is filled to the brim?
I'm very tempted to...
do scripts picked by you guys for Patreon.
Uh, after my kissy script went up,
I literally was so happy producing it and it was so fun and such a goof-off, I'm like...
Oh, sugar.
I'm like, I think I need a new tactic.
That doesn't do anything?
Wait, he's coded to be stuck inside the ring?
No, I have to tell me twice!
Put a bow, that's why they're...
Ow!
Are you serious?
Oh my god, I'm actually gonna die because of that?
Bruh.
Stop it.
I lost all my coins!
I need those to invest!
How dare you?
Ow, why am I getting so beaten up?
Right, enough, enough, enough.
Right, back off, back off.
Just hit from afar.
It keeps...
It literally throws me forward when I do that attack.
Literally getting wallets.
Bruh, that's such a...
I fell for greed!
The game really said don't be greedy.
How dare you?
Stealing my coins.
I need to invest, okay?
Let me invest.
I was thinking about doing a stream talking about, like, the video games I want to make, but...
Well, I won't make them.
I'll pay someone to develop.
That audio.
Maybe ink?
Inkling.
No!
Oh no, we're gonna get jumpscared doing that.
Okay, let's see some sort of...
Well, that doesn't look like a platform just so far.
The Dark Souls of the Sonic series.
God, the game really wants you to do those, like, little save mission things.
I refuse.
Well, that certainly looks like the right way.
Almost done.
Okay.
Need a ring, don't worry, I got...
Oh my god, let's have a wedding.
And let's have a billion children.
But I don't birth them.
But I don't want you to birth them either.
We don't do impreg around here.
But also, at the same time, I don't want to birth them.
So we're gonna have to figure out something between us.
Seems like a dude.
Huh.
There's a platform.
Oh!
Oh no, I missed my raid!
Okay, I need to let it spank down again.
Adoption.
No breed, only pregnant.
Need a nerdy hacker girl in Gen 4 that make the games for you.
I'm worried about giving anyone lore where I have to give them actual notes on their existence.
That's the only thing I'm worried about.
So everyone's lore is straightforward.
I say she was so happy when she got Icy and I revealed what the creation behind her was.
She was like, she's literally so me.
So it was really good fit.
Is this trolling me?
Am I gonna drop and it's gonna drop with me?
Or do I need to like bait it and just spanking me?
Oh, okay, I need it to bait it.
And it was just like,
I'm worried about giving the girl, cause I was actually, right, okay.
This is, oh my gosh.
Oh no, not one of these.
Should we grind on it to crossover?
Should we grind on it?
Oh, I'll grind on it already.
Right, easy, easy.
Right, if we stay on.
Oh no, we're going the wrong way.
You know what?
That worked out in the end.
I got what I wanted.
Right, we're gonna be on 50 now.
Lore never seems to matter anyway.
No, it doesn't.
At first I was actually considering getting an airplane girl,
like based after either SR71,
most likely SR71.
I'm really biased towards that plane.
Hold on, I need to make my way over here.
Gently.
Need to make my way over.
What comes up?
Hold on, I'm getting shagged on the rails.
Okay, there we go.
No.
Right, we're just gonna 100% nobody fucking...
Pishy missions then.
I ain't doing all that twice.
There's a switch up there.
Beat him up!
Thank you, tiny spainy, and witness void forks seven.
What comes up must go down.
Yet my feet don't touch the ground.
See the world spinning upside down.
A mighty crash was found inside.
Right, do not touch the lasers.
What, just...
I'm dumb.
I'm very low IQ.
Please forgive.
Let's go on a character that's a little bit lower.
Do you do...
Can you break these?
No, you can't.
Meh!
I'm gonna pretend this is the answer.
Whoa!
Okay, that was the answer.
Turn invisible.
Yes.
S.P.O. isn't hurt when invisible.
Oh, he's getting beaten up down there.
Yes, you will take the lead.
At least destroy the ones that are vulnerable.
That would be great.
Is there one still here?
No, no.
There's no secret one.
No.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Back at it again with my favorite channel.
What's your favorite character in Sonic?
I'm asking my brother E.Flings this too.
Mine is Knuckles.
Knuckles?
I think for his child I was definitely Knuckles.
Why is this place so scary?
Bro, get me out of here.
I don't even...
I really hope that didn't count.
Look, there are torches here too.
Alright, Halo.
John Halo from the hit video game Halo.
I'm gonna just blast.
Anyway, I thought it was blasted.
Thank you, reverse for the super chat.
No.
Silver!
I don't even...
What's Silver's lore?
I like Rogue the Bat, but that's because she's...
She's sexy.
I like Rose as well.
I used to watch a lot of Sonic Hero and Rose fan art compilation music videos or something.
Oh, please don't be at the start.
Huh?
I can't go back?
Oh no.
I missed four?
I didn't miss any.
How can I have missed four?
Oh no.
You missed four in the evil room?
I was supposed to float to that.
Could I stand on them maybe?
They were right there in the second last room.
Ah.
Whoopsie daisy.
Gotcha boys.
We know someone that switched trigger.
Okay, well thankfully we can kinda just zoom on by then if they're all in the last room.
At least you don't have to re-kill the most of the enemies.
Yeah.
The K.
So the other missions they gave so much like extra,
but they're not really giving extra anything anymore.
Which is a shame because that's kinda like...
K.O. is a team chaotic.
I think it's team chaotic.
That was the fun of playing them because they're like quirky.
They're different.
I'll see if I need to do the switch.
Sonic's my favourite character now.
Ah.
Oh, no.
Okay, we hit the switch.
And then we head back.
Oh, that was not the character I was supposed to use for that segment.
I mean, I'll take it.
Okay, so this is already open.
That's good.
And...
I assume that's just that big old hole down there.
Mummy's gonna have fun at the insane level?
It's allies!
And it's coming this way.
Right, crazy world.
Look for crazy world and then try and extinguish the flames in it.
Right, you need to jinx it.
You need to tease it.
Oh, yeah.
That big hole down there, you see?
Bob me and I after the reform.
Is the door open?
That looks open to me.
Okay.
Alright, fucking steady on the speed mate, Jesus.
That worked out very well.
Diplicate the sonic cow in your head.
Wait, why?
Why would I do that?
Am I being dumb?
Right, we just need the scary level now.
Right, scary level now?
Oh, sorry.
Okay, scary level now.
What am I supposed to do, though?
This looks like I just...
You can walk on the ground.
That's...
1.
That's nonsense.
2.
That is...
How am I supposed to ken that?
Is the pumpkins on the ground supposed to be the indication, probably?
How did mommy miss it?
I thought there was no floor,
so I didn't take it as one that you could actually interact with.
That took me 23 minutes of running.
23 minutes of wandering around that castle?
No problem.
Yeah, it's meant to mess with you.
I think the flames are mad.
Well, like, everything else is in a skull hand as well.
You know what?
I'm blaming the game.
Sorry, but I'm blaming the game into emoji.
Oh, shit.
You must dash moron.
Take him out.
Quickly.
B for boss.
B for B.
The contrast of the root ones at any given time.
B for boobla.
The client's Eggman!
How can you tell?
Yes.
Literally the level off on the one I want it on.
Amazing.
Oh, come on.
In from.
He's up there.
There we go.
We got level off.
Smash them all.
Yeah.
See, he only pauses them right now.
He doesn't.
I love that.
Just spank, spank, spank, spank, spank, spank, spank, spank.
Alright, let's just blow him up.
Does mommy know that Team Blast is?
No.
Are you about to teach me something I should know about?
Use Team Blast.
You're going to recharge it.
Because of the money you get.
Whoa.
When you kill enemies for the next few seconds, you get ring.
And then a level got my...
Yeah, the rings fill it.
She doesn't know.
I'm not that smart.
Thank you.
Okay, now we're all leveled up.
Wee!
Yeah, the rings in here to get their Team Blast goes forward to the next one.
A few thundershoot and swap to Esquil on the same frame.
It fills the bar up super far.
How strange.
Oh, where are we going?
Oh!
Wait, this mission isn't just on...
What?
That's so cool!
This mission isn't a one singular platform?
Oh my gosh.
Well, we're just going to use my ultimate because everyone's got shields.
What?
That's the first time I've done a fight and it's not all on the same platform.
Like, for this type of map.
Thank you.
Oh shit, he's getting it.
Here we go.
Awesome!
Oh my god, I have explosive bubbles.
You dropping bombs on me!
I'm dropping a nuke on you.
I'm dropping an album right now.
Mostly spam Team Blast and good for life on you.
You're going to max out the rings at 99 if you don't get hurt.
Oh, I didn't even know you could do that.
The game had enough.
The game's like, okay, you beat me.
You win.
Thank you, B.
Whoa!
Okay, thank goodness Esquil's all leveled up.
She's slow.
Okay, we don't even need to use our ultimate for this fight
because it's just the easier planes.
Oh, it's one of these ones.
Wait.
Sorry, hold on a minute.
I'm a low IQ.
I'm just a meme or part two.
Oh, I really do not like this.
I'm sure it's fine and all, but I do not trust the game
where 10 foot pull when it comes to landing on these things.
It just makes me so nervous that I'm going to go flying off the map.
I'm just doing this in a row so we can hit them a bit better.
You can stand on the track as charming.
Oh, shit.
That is so much easier.
Thank you.
That was the bird.
Can you get the bird?
Does the bird not count?
No, you don't want the bird?
Okay, let's...
No.
Right, we need to try and hit the bird on the way over
because I'm out of range.
One, two, three.
Okay, I was way too late.
Way too late.
Think about the travel distance.
Okay, wait for it to come by.
Okay, one, two, three.
Surely one of...
Are you joking?
Come on.
Right, let's try again.
There's no way I'm stuck here until if I get the bird.
One, two, three.
Okay, okay, we did it.
We did it.
No, take me out.
No, don't keep putting me back in.
Please.
Don't put me back in again.
Stop putting me back in.
Let me out.
No, it won't.
It won't let me out.
Right.
Right, okay.
No.
Let me out.
There has to be a way to get out of this cannon.
Please.
No.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Can I do this or something?
And then swap to the character that I throw out.
Okay, okay, it's fine.
I'm sorry.
I'm so low IQ.
I was like spamming all the buttons, but nothing was happening.
I actually stuck in game.
Hailed hostage by Monty.
Okay, where are we going?
That way?
Who?
More, more, more, more, more.
Okay, fuck everything up right now.
And she didn't shoot herself into the void.
A clip worthy, we're at 108.
No, that's embarrassing.
Because I'll have to turn into an actual foot that goes on the channel.
I mean, I'm stuck.
Help me step.
I'm stuck.
I might as well just team blast, honestly.
Sounds like getting out of the chart is the war.
I'm stuck.
I can't do this.
Who was he?
He was.
So close to 99 rings.
Damn.
Do I get anything special for 99?
I wouldn't assume so.
Let's take them all out.
I love the babe.
That's it, be beachable right now.
Oh, we're on the airships.
Who won?
Oh.
Oh my God, that was so cute.
Don't get detected by the enemies.
Wait, so that just...
Hold on, let me just...
Wait, this is the whole mission still?
So there's sections that I can...
And then what, I lose?
I can't even get over.
Oh.
I mean, there's an enemy right behind me.
I assume I just...
The game will just put me back to a checkpoint if I mess up.
Oh.
Wait, what?
Excuse me?
Hello?
There must be a way around.
Excuse me, I would just like to take that, please.
Okay.
What a unique...
Did we not have to do this on the jungle, now that I remember?
Oh, uh...
Hold on a minute.
I can almost make it!
Yeah, I can almost...
I can even get up!
Okay, nice checkpoint.
Oh, that breaks them.
Okay, fly over.
I assume these bots don't count like the...
The auto aim lock guns?
Yeah.
Look at all those ships!
I wonder if we could take one.
Okay, here we go.
No, hold on.
Put me at the top, and then...
How?
Oh, what?
There's like a secret path?
Sorry, I don't trust it.
I want to be invisible.
I don't trust this mission!
I've never played it before.
I have no trust.
Wait, they don't just...
Shit!
Wait, what happens now?
Are they too dumb to care?
Only sleeping enemies count.
Oh!
Can you guys stay on it?
Why don't you stay on it?
Yeah, there you go.
Mr. B?
Mr. B, stop it!
There, jeez.
Okay.
It's invisible again.
Literally, maybe this game is a bit fairer than I once thought.
Can I, like, invis through this?
Beep beep beep, Charlie!
I'm nervous.
Okay, so it's only sleeping enemies.
Okay, careful, easy.
I'm to hit all of these?
Chips?
Chips, chips, chips, chips, chips, chips, chips, chips, chips, chips, chips.
Oh, well, that was kind of inevitable, to be honest.
Okay, let's get over here.
What platform are you playing on?
The ex-folks original version?
Is that what you're asking?
Hee hee.
I'm looking around.
Oh, there's, like, switches here.
What, the switches are on the sides?
To open what?
I even know to open something.
I'll just continue.
Not my concern, not my problem.
Until it is.
So that's not asleep, so can I just do this?
I don't know.
Are there any other games you want to play on Sonic?
Probably.
Camera angles, steady on.
It would be...
Maybe Sonic Unleashed.
I'll need to watch someone else.
Oh, he did it!
I didn't mess it up!
Oh, I thought I was going to mess it up!
Please shadow the hedgehog. Is that a natural game?
It may be.
I was, like, unfortunately I didn't complete Sonic Rush as a kid,
because I kept getting stuck. I couldn't see what was ahead of me.
Like, I used to just zoom through the game.
He, like, unironically has guns.
Yeah, it's a sequel to Sonic Heroes...
Eh, to Heroes and Sonic Adventure 2.
Okay, maybe, maybe.
Not bad. No complaints.
Maybe some complaints.
Am I about to do the boss play?
I think it goes airshifting and then, like,
Final Fortress.
Uh-huh.
We need five keys!
Oh, I can do that!
We'll meet our clients and...
Susie clients.
Okay.
What do the X's mean?
I'm not sure.
Uh-huh.
Uh, right. Five keys.
And we can save our client.
Are you serious?
You spawned in everywhere!
I could spank the game.
Literally on my head.
I literally got teabagged mid-air.
What was I supposed to do?
My ground isn't shaking, is it?
Oh, I didn't need to grab that key.
I can't believe that, right?
He spawns in the air!
Right. He's still...
Peace off, mate.
I am speed.
Whoa, but not like that, not like that, not like that!
Not that kind of speed.
Oh, there it is. I see it!
I'm gonna grab a call in a second, actually.
Right, there's a hidden key behind me.
I feel like there's a key behind me.
That was so much real estate down there.
And if there isn't, I'm gonna be mad.
No, I'm mad.
I thought there was a key down here!
No, alright. Well, I didn't exactly waste my time.
It's been like five seconds.
We're fine. We're good.
Power?
Right!
Good reflexes.
Am I still so many times as a kid doing that?
I'm just gonna spam until I get ult,
because his hammer scares me so much.
Yeah, get right.
How much sleep did you get?
I got five hours.
I thought I could 100% this game,
but I'm getting a bit nervous.
I thought we would have been finished
Team Chaotic by now,
because it is said that we were on 73%,
but as you can see, we're still going,
so my idea wasn't the best.
So trying 100% this game to do.
Nah, his repointy thing got me.
Get rid of that shield!
Only five hours?
No, so what happened is after stream yesterday,
I did get like six hours,
and it helped a lot doing that,
as we're having to be here.
It did help a lot doing that,
because I was working reviewing these audios
that had edited for me.
And I was able to finalize Azura's graphics
to advertise her Jonathan.
So once that weight room is up,
you're actually gonna see the trailer.
It's like a very calm and relaxed trailer,
which I don't know, controversial.
People might not like it,
but honestly, I liked how it wasn't like some crazy meme.
It was just like, hi, you'll see it when it's available type thing.
I really not hurt him when he thought that shield thing was going on.
Oh, I really can't, well.
Right, we'll get out of here then.
And like I was able to finalize that all.
No, not that kind of key.
Sorry guys, see you later, see you on the other side.
Not my problem.
And then it took me a while to get to sleep though.
I need to fucking stop using my sleep medication,
which is really annoying,
because it does put me to sleep,
but it's just...
You know what, I'm gonna fuck up.
You know, many or most people tend to finish games over time.
I know we might be suspicious
about how things are normally done,
but I think it'll be worth it.
For a 20-hour endurance game, honestly.
Right, we've got three keys now.
We need two more.
We must uncage the reeflings.
They're locked up right now.
We'll be close for sure.
Sorry.
What?
That's a new mechanic, okay?
You can't blame me for messing that up her...
Oh, I'm dead.
That's a new mechanic, okay?
That's a new mechanic.
You cannot blame me for not understanding one area.
I was just like, ooh, fancy legs.
That was a new mechanic.
Right.
Okay, next time I see that,
I will move a little to the right.
Because I was just like, ooh, fancy legs.
But this is awfully late games
to be introduced in mechanics like that.
So late.
So in my defense, I'm allowed to be a dumb dumb.
It's red.
No, it's pink and blue.
Oh, please.
This isn't a fight.
If all you do is defend.
Okay, we got that one.
There was something here.
What is it?
That was just moaning.
After this level,
we'll go get a cooler.
Alright, sorry.
A hydration.
I was like hydration check
and I took a sip of my cooler
and someone was like,
strong ink cooler is not hydration, you dusk.
I might make some smooth actually.
What did I do?
Oh, a sweep of cool.
To be fair,
isn't it a little bit hydrating?
Ah, there we go.
POV, my 3D concert.
Sorry, Veeler's concert.
Sure, give me this.
Am I supposed to jump down?
Oh, there's a full.
Cool badge.
Behind you?
Was that actually behind me?
Am I about to do a 360
around this entire map again?
I mean, it's not hydration.
Trouble is it comes to a bunch of other stuff
that probably make you feel worse off.
If I have to redo this whole map
because I'm an idiot and it was back there,
I'm gonna cry.
As I'm saying, the early end game
was so kind.
Why on earth have they made this structure?
Is there a key at the end of this?
Be honest.
How unique?
I don't think they've done a structure like that yet.
If you're drinking in hydration blooms,
there was a destroyable block
that'll be where it is.
I'm gonna put it back to the start.
I don't want to go back to the start of the game.
I can't believe it.
I don't...
There's a stripper pole there.
There's something in there.
Maybe a key?
Oh my...
Stop! The freaking hammer!
God, I really just like that guy.
No, I'm not even touching him.
I can't get close to him.
I can't get close to him now.
Can I beat him up?
How is this?
Oh!
Enemy's up ahead!
Nope. You're not getting me.
Sorry, you're unironically not getting me.
I'll be back later. Good luck.
Thank you.
I'm gonna need it.
Honestly, so I know a team rose
only takes like three hours or something
of that, mate.
See that hammer?
It's going anytime.
Right, no, fuck it. We're just blowing him up.
God, I'm so used to code strongy
for 10% off camera stuff.
Bro, I got emails
after the membership stream.
It was like, you have made a commission.
Congrats!
Um, because
we're reffing the marriage.
I'm like, bro, we're gonna have to make a meta roleplay
where I'm a...
doing something now.
What it is, we'll never know.
Can you grab that, please?
Thank you. You know that thing
that's right in front of you? Can you grab that?
Mm-mm.
Didn't save it for the...
Right, we have the fifth key.
Team rose super fast.
Apparently team dark, super long
and hard, just like...
8-8-2.
Mission complete.
Yeah, I guess you hear Vector's cover
of Stacey's mom.
Use the chaos emeralds to turn
into super strong. No, it's not happening.
I'm faking them up.
I was watching Imi play it yesterday
and she was like, I just need a few more emeralds
and then something happens
and I'm like, oh yeah, I know what she's on.
About, I did not.
There were actually tankies on the stage.
Luckily, you didn't have to do them. Yeah, like...
Oh, we're in a...
Power.
Enough of this.
That's the old timey Vector.
Time to meet young Vector.
We won!
I'll show you what real evil is.
I don't remember how to defeat him.
This must be the final stage.
Is that it?
Not really, boys. This is where we have to get tough.
Don't put your scars down.
Oh, yay!
Sorry, I'm tryharding.
So the problem is, if I actually
don't keep up with his speed,
he will, like, come flying at me
at this platform.
Okay, we're already levelled up enough to do that.
What about him, though?
Okay, we can shoot his chest.
I would prefer to play it safe
than to play it safe.
Prefer to play it safe
than dangerous.
We're at 75.
60 net hit.
I just would prefer to play it safe.
I really hope we can stun lock him
to stay here.
No way!
Please! Please!
I'm edging right now.
No!
No, no, no, no, no! Do it!
Do it! Do it!
Oh, no!
You can't do that mid plate!
This is why you can't do it mid plate
because that happens.
Yes!
Oh, my God! Wait, that was the boss.
We did it!
Oh, my God!
We like, stun locked him on that.
We stun locked him. That was so good.
Did I get an A?
I get an A!
I'm so good!
I got an A!
Oh!
Can't see him!
Oh, he melted.
You're insane!
Dr. Eggman, I presume.
What's going on?
What's up?
You knew it was me all along,
or didn't you?
You're a run!
It's no trick.
Besides, I plan on paying you.
You'll be rewarded handsomely
for helping me as soon as
I conquer the world.
I will pay you!
Some nerve!
Take this, you bad man!
Oh, my gosh!
We did it! That's the first time
I've ever completed Team Chaotic.
We've been had!
Take this, you bad refling!
This is a very unique
Eritreous song.
Time to walk out to this song
in the game.
I've never heard it!
I've never seen it!
That's 2 out of 4, yes.
Team Rose is easy peasy.
You don't have to think about it.
It's Team Dark I'm worried about
because I've never played it before.
Oh, my gosh!
Tracking down your crimes!
That's the first time
I've ever played it.
I've never played it.
I love this!
I don't want to talk over the song too much.
There's so much love
that went into these older games.
Like,
4 pathways, they all have their unique
ending song, congrats, cutscenes, etc.
Like,
crossover.
I'm not being
I'm not just being
like a debbie donor
or whatever the terminology is when I'm like
Try another story!
Hey, it's my thumbnail.
Hey, they stole my thumbnail!
Like,
I'm not going to meta when it's just kind of like
it seems like
dev teams were allowed to actually create
something they wanted to
whereas now it's just all fucking publishers
in their neck.
Team Rose!
Okay, here we go.
That's just my side dialogue.
Ah,
Big Duggo,
the consequences of shareholders
and game companies being
publicly treated.
You can breathe them a neck into it.
Me, my actual dialogue.
Apparently there was this Sonic game
where you farm those little things,
that blue thing.
But like, you look after them and stuff
and it was such a good game.
People loved it, but they never made a remaster
of it or something.
I want to!
Right, I'm going to pause
so I can quickly make some food and get a cola
and a water.
Sonic Adventure 2?
Yeah, it was like you farmed them.
I see you're breathing in your neck.
Hey, are you almost done coding that yet?
Yeah, I have no idea.
Do you know what the password is to my email?
People.
Yes, I'm going to very quickly make
some toast and a cheese and ham sandwich.
It's not a sandwich.
Wait, no, it's just, it is a sandwich
even if you toast it, because it's not a toast
because I'm not putting in a toast though.
I'm not putting in a toasty maker.
I'm just putting toast and ham
and cheese together. Is that what you think?
A sandwich.
A sanga!
But you always eat that, eh?
The
Chow Garden was just so good in that game.
It's a real shame they never remade it.
Don't worry, I'm going to
come out with not
Chow Garden. Like, I'll produce
the game. It'll totally
you know, not get any...
I'm not going to get sued by Sega
when I make it okay.
I'll make sure it's got the elements
but it's different, you know?
Yeah?
How about we do that?
We'll come up with it together.
Lasagna is a sandwich.
What a brave thing to say.
Why would it even be considered
a sandwich? That's not possible.
I love that game so much. It puts so many
errors into Chow Garden.
Let's go, baby!
Legally distinct. The Reefling Garden!
Reefling Paradise
we'll call it.
Because
when it comes to like the video games
I want to produce at a later date.
Obviously, I do want hidden
things in it.
But Reeflings are really cute.
So we could take Grim Your Own Stronik
Wrong Lasagna Spaghetti Flavored Cake.
What is that?
Is this some internet argument I'm not
part of yet?
Someone said
would you say
Aura Aura
if I gave you onions?
I literally have just produced a video
and it's me going
ada ada into the mic
but in a photoshop accent.
So it's funny that someone
asked for that.
Someone says I think you can hypnotise
us using your feet.
I hit
the writers
like disguised
kink.
Because what? Wait, what's the
meme?
What is it?
The writers barely disguised
um
I think I'm a bobber.
I can't believe something.
Okay, let me
like all the comments on
I need to approve of all the
comments.
Did you guys see my new short?
I like
so I'm going to test out a short
series. You're not ready for it.
Okay
You're not ready for my short series.
Oh no, he's onto something. How can you hypnotise
with feet? That's not even possible.
Authors barely disguised.
There you go. The totally spiced thing.
On
my hypnosis stream, someone said
you can hypnotise us with your feet as well, you know.
Right, okay.
Um
Yeah, I was like mucking about
and I was like, no, no, no, I'm not going to do it. Fine.
You're my wee pogchamp. I'm going to
attempt a short series
which is memes
but Scottish. That's it.
So it's like a succulent Chinese
Mio
Eh, what is the crime?
He's got my penis.
Like that basically is what the shorts
are going to be. So I was going to voice
over and just it just call it memes
but Scottish and then I'd maybe give
it three attempts and, you know, if it doesn't
really get anywhere, I'll go back to doing regular stuff.
For shorts
if you want to get into the content
aenosis, um
don't, no, don't think it, don't think it Emmy.
Don't think of Emmy in her
adorable
panties in that video. No, don't
think about it. Don't think
about it.
You're not thinking about how she was
been over.
Don't think about it.
Um
after analyzing
the content, it
on, on, if
you want my biased
opinion because I've not done enough research on the
subject and I can admit that, it appears
that
Brian
I'm going to dip now.
Have fun brothers. And strongy
don't forget that I am always here to support.
Love you.
Love you too little reflin. Thank you for the super chat
reverse.
Oh, it's so sweet.
Um
Too late, I'm thinking about it.
Um, what was I saying?
Oh, pre-recorded shorts that are
edited versus like a live
moment in a live stream seem to
perform better
as a whole. Now that is my ignorant
ignoramus
aenosis. I wouldn't mind doing like
a content analysis
stream. I probably would sound really boring
but I find
analytics it comes from a fruit and
is liquid
Yes
Yes, I agree with that.
Thank you the beauty lords for the super chat.
I actually agree with that one.
I, I don't think it's
that con, that's not a controversial one. I think
that's actually alright. Um
but
I find
um analytics really
interesting
but I don't know if that's because I'm boring in a content creator.
Um, like
Emmy's short
when it blew up
um, it was just
a fantastic combination of everything
and I'm so glad it did
um, like
I got a marshmallow that was like
uh
it was something along the lines of I'm happy
that you're happy for Emmy's short
but they said something along the lines of
sorry reflin, I'm gonna like paraphrase
this because I can't quite remember the terminology
used. It was like
it was the best short
to blow up as well
because it spoke
about what the agency does
because I mean
I've kind of like dogged on, not dogged on it
I can't, but you know what, I might as well
just play the game and talk in the background. Um
oh my controller went to sleep
wait no it didn't
um, I'll make food in a minute
um
and I've completely forgot what I was gonna say
now a bit of the game, wait
I genuinely can't do two things at once
um
what was I saying? I forgot
I forgot, I literally
have forgot
I forgot, mommy don't stop
no no no no, it's okay
um, reflin and talk
about the Emmy, oh right
I've kind of said this a few times now
so you can just close your ears
because it's like bruh, we've already heard that
we're paired up a few times over now, yes
um
I'm aware that there is a bit of
stigma around us as a company
but like I feel like
I couldn't have made it any easier
to like comprehend that like hey
we're just regular streamers, it's just offered on the side
like it's not a big deal
unless you make it a big deal
I like
I don't, ugh
I think just because
I don't put any
like seriousness behind it
or like this means
this person showed a picture
of their bum
you know like I don't
it doesn't shock me
I'm like if you look at the average bikini
like
I don't know, I think
my brain's just wired a bit differently
compared to the average Joe so it doesn't like shock me
but I'm really glad like
she has two, sorry
three more shorts coming
which are really
good
I hope
one in particular
gets that popular
cause she's talking about like the behind the scenes stuff
which I adore
the behind the scenes content
it's my favourite kind of stuff to like talk about
sorry that was my inside voice
um
hi Miss Johnny, hi Miss Lynn
just remembered the 20K picture
ah yes
um
I still have the meme, I'm gonna post the meme at 25K
cause it's like there
um
uh
the dumpy
but like none of it, it just
uh
it just doesn't mean nothing
bye bye
uh
y'all are shivers yourself people go
yeah like um it was interesting
to read the feedback she got
a lot of it was like solo tubers
and it was like no
not lude tubers, solo tubers
are when you go
tee hee
and then crack a joke here and there type thing
um
what ab tubers are
actually produce the goods
you know they don't just
be like eee hee hee hee
etc
like no they actually produce the goods
it's not just like one little blue ball
in session every stream, you know what I mean
okay we learned through that
thank you Gaming Kitsune
except um
it's not just baiting and being in a bikini
yes a lot of
the comments I saw on the shore
was like oh
um
so you mean lude tubers so you mean like what this
uh this v-tuber does
and it's like no the shore
literally explain
um
what an ab tubers
versus a lude tuber
I'm playing the easiest
easiest
and you're telling me I'm perishing
you put out is the phrase
we back
up our claims of
wanting to groom you
stop don't
don't that's not funny
you're not allowed to say that lude
stop saying that lude
back up your claims or your preach
well only others preach
yeah it was just interesting seeing the feedback
like someone commented on
Emmy's short recently it was
along the lines of like finally someone that actually
explained that that isn't
just uh like
that knows the difference
cause
yeah there is definitely a lot of like
you guys are just lude tubers and it's like
no a lude tubers when they go
ehehe and crack a little joke
an abtuber is
you know what
we do
come right now
that's basically it
um
she's grooming us
as big as
the big cutie
I don't know what that means
are you calling
I'm just saying Gimli's got a tum tum
Gimli has
the cutest tummy I love her tummy
we vehicles
we've been doing great as well
although
um
I've come to a horrible
realisation about my
uh darling
Viggo
um
so Gimli and Viggo were like rescue
cats it wasn't like I bought them
as kittens I don't buy
I adopt
don't shop I think it's a terminology
um
and
the
the person
that adopted them from
they were basically like
look
they came from a harder home
we don't have much information
okay but actually real and true
thank you internet basil file
cause it's true
oh my gosh
it's a cute
um
yeah
like she just did perfect
and she's got a few more coming that are like that
and I'm so excited cause
oh my girls deserve all the success
in the world and I love them
and they're so amazing
anyway
that's me
um
I miss clicked now you see my
underwear meanwhile mommy
someone sent me a marshmallow they're like
I still go back to the Grumman audio
cause it's absolutely hilarious every time
they were like I literally
I assume what I mean is like
oh I literally like
dorkin the peanut
and like having a giggle at the same time
wait like that's the best kind
if you're having a giggle whilst like
you know
oh that's what my point was earlier
um
are you a cuttlehog
or a hedge fish
a cuttlehog sounds very unique
um
my voice literally cannot
even keep up with that
um
yes that's why I was saying like
so I recorded
um
in advance for Patreon
but I am like
I'm
very ready to
um
just end up doing scripts
that we all choose together
cause I just feel so much more
rewarded when I put something out
that we came up with versus that we didn't
she's an edging
fish what
that didn't
what
um
ow my face
so I do have stuff
but
don't be
surprised if I'm like
I'm not even in this
and we're just gonna make new stuff together
um
cause
yeah
a hedge fish oh hedge
you know what you're done
you're done the grooming girls one was funny
yeah like that stuff is just
it's so giffy it's so fun
and it's like I know
you guys wanted it cause we literally made it together
whereas like the other stuff
I was just kind of taking a shot in the dark like
um
I got a lot of feedback when the girls collab
audios came out
um
I will admit
I completely misjudged
um
what people wanted
I honestly thought
that the collab audios would have been really
well received cause it's like oh you're too
two v-tubers interacting
together
and like I don't mind admitting that I was wrong
and I did it wrong like
it's not a problem
just
it was just a bit eye-opening
being like oh I actually didn't like
that there was two of you together
cause like I'd rather just
it be on your own type thing
um
and uh
yeah like I'm glad that I could learn
and be like okay like that wasn't
maybe the best choice
um
and like I'm fine to admit that
I'm allowed to be wrong
I don't like the collabs not gonna like
yeah so
about that
um
so there isn't going to be any more
patreon collabs
after the feedback
um
so there won't be like you pay to hear a collab
that's not gonna be a thing
Mr. Big please
your hitbox is humongous is it not
um
that's what I want you to be sounding like
why did it do that right but do Amy then
nah
god damn it I believe me
no no no
you need to listen to my words
you're not going to be paying
via patreon for any
collab audios
it's not paid anymore does that make sense
so it's not
never gonna happen again
there's just no more on patreon it's gonna be
the girls solo from now on
um and I am thankful
for the structured feedback
like as I said I can't get it
right all the time and I genuinely
was under the impression like
I'll literally
right okay I'll literally I was cooking the script
so I'm gonna be like yeah them hos gonna
love this okay
okay so they're free
wait so they're
free now yes if any future
collab audios are gonna be free
to access because
it made people uncomfortable
you know
they want to hear who they
have patreon to
and I misjudged it
and I'm happy to say that yes we do
oh unbelievable
breaking news each of our agency
actually takes feedback
shocking
truly
cooking so much she burned it yes
I burned it and I can admit it and it's okay
so as I said
any collabs will now be public free
access
and what happens on patreon
is just solo from now it's only
gonna be the girl that's in it
I misjudged it I'm okay
to I'm happy to admit it I got it
wrong and equally I am happy
for the feedback
that I was given
to like help make things better
so I obviously because of
the feedback it means I can adjust and be
like okay so patreon isn't gonna
like we're not putting it on patreon
it's just gonna be free access when the girls do a collab
together and either you can
you know enjoy it or you can
just do your thing
you know if it's on both girls
patreon what's the issue
the issue was that
people found it a bit uncomfortable
to hear
another girl when they signed up
to hear one girl does that make sense
so if you want to
access future collabs
it's gonna be free access
so you don't have to pay for it okay
now there's nothing in the
works right now
like in terms of that
it may be milestone stuff I think
I think milestone stuff is a really
good way to
oh that doesn't do any damage
okay there we go
does that make sense
no I'm sorry
what I don't get it
okay so
for example I collab with
Mersey Mersey collabs with me
a snippet only wants to hear
Mersey they don't want to hear my accent
they go on Mersey's patreon to support
Mersey they hear me why did they hear me
they don't want to hear me they didn't sign up to
hear me does that make sense
so now
patreon will only have
role plays from the girl
you signed up for Mersey you're only gonna
hear Mersey
there might be
collab audios but they're gonna be
free access public that's gonna be posted
on the alt twitter type thing
yeah
how they don't want to hear you
no no it's different
it's different
it's just an example I'm subbed to all six of you
so it makes literally no difference
oh my god thank you for the support
holy shit
I do sometimes
get a few marshmallows that are like who does
support I will always proudly
say please support the girls over me
I am very lucky in the
position I am in in the support
I have received
and
when it comes to
my
donathon I hope
it's
it's very clear
what good
times are ahead of us
and it's just really nice that all the girls
have been supported like
it's
crazy to think that
Azura is
in the very real position where she might be able
to move out and if this
donathon goes fantastically well like
and she worked so hard to
with me to come up with things that genuinely
feel like a reward
and
I took previous feedback
of being like can the public rewards not be
exclusive
and I took that into
account and
a lot of the stuff is public
and there's a few
exceptions but it is
the most like
traditional stuff like please
don't please don't think
that like oh I can't give money
the agency
oh
right let's try that again
I don't even know how to manage that
eh
I support
viewer
there is
a lot of them can we do this
without dying this time though that's my question
can we stick to the middle
Amy
let's stick to the middle
team or friend
okay that I keep doing
that that is not what that's for
my head
is spinning
okay we did it that time
hey mama
I'm off work and I was thinking
you love backseat gaming and banal
I think those are connected
you want a refling to be your literal
backseat so you can get banal
while we backseat you
am I right or am I right
now opening apps for this
okay there's this artwork that I can't
find okay now
it's mildly related to what you said tiny
spiny thank you
Stronic Sonic Heroes
C4
we're trying to do 100%
we're doing team rosin we're just blasting
through it right now because it's literally
the easiest team
there's this
forbidden artwork
it's forbidden
and it's by this artist
and I can't find it and it's gonna
annoy me for the rest of my days
I'm sure it can come across it at some point
but
I'm
juice
beat him up beat him up beat him up
got it got it
a preach brother
I'm pretty sure I know which one
I mean I'd be
very surprised why is it
forbidden it's
it's an artist
okay so the artist draws
herself I'm pretty sure it's
a girl artist and
and
she had I must see this artwork
the C4 I'm nervous to say
in front of you
call me the generous
but
basically
the artist draws themself
as their muse and I
kid you not she's like
at her
PC and she's like stood off a bit
and she has
a
a plug
but I can't find it and it was
so well rendered so well
detailed like it was very high quality
and
electric
I'm very
yeah that describes like 40 images
by female artist and I know
I'll maybe draw it from memory and I'll
put everyone on a wild goose hunt to find
this one particular artwork and then
when we find it I'll literally
at the artwork at the artist and I'll
be like I love you so much for this one artwork
just to show
artist appreciation if I find
anything littering appropriate about
sweeten innocence trying I'm gonna leave it
now
we're in trouble
doesn't narrow it down look
I'll draw a sixth man figure on MS
paint I'm gonna grab this real quick
I'm getting an a star
for this level
I'm getting a plus because I'm so good at this
that maybe
your art
it is anime
we did it
oh my god this is why I'm an architect
because I'm look at them pushing
the belly on mr. B
you should post a stick figure
on Twitter and see if someone can actually track it down
I think I may just for the house
just for the heck of it
you forgot the key no
I don't pick up the keys on purpose I don't
want to pay I don't want to play the bubble
levels the bubble levels and I'm so much
anime
style okay that helps that drops it down to
it render doesn't it's like anime style
but rendered anime style
like you know when it's got a bit more
detail than the average like anime
okay we're fully maxed
out on
I tried
damn
they really want a
cream to be
leveled up
fit mommy yes yes
I'm really enjoying team
Rose because they're so easy and straight
forward and I don't have to think for them
I
had it
I don't think I've ever taken this path
before that was rather scary don't do that
again
let's level her up
level 3 flying
is OP
the flying ones
okay
okay that's
a strange
Sonic Heroes moment
nice
that was very unique
cream got stuck
we did it
you okay but you good
no literally the flying ones
always
like carries so hard in this game
they're like so quick they're so efficient
they're so fast
and like you one shot things as well
so when it comes to the gameplay you're not even
having a sweat
you
the speed one just everyone
I really like the level up system that you
get like stronger the more like low points
you have I think it's like
quite a good detail how did I miss
everything okay there we go
put me on the rails
close enough but if you want
the final boss you've got to get the emeralds
by doing the special stages
in stages to have each zone
doing them as rose is easiest since
their stages are short
what I'm going to do
controversial take
reflin very controversial tiny
tiny
I'm going to 100%
everyone's missions
and if I have it in me to continue
I will
I will come back to team rose
and grab the keys
how about that I'll make you a deal
if I have it in me another eight I'm just so good
flying characters are also the most
bug though I do have to agree with that
how controversial and brave
marry me
okay
each of our obsessed with marriage
character what would she be
which should be a widow
I'm fucking them up I don't know what's going on
down there but I'm fucking them up
I'm fucking them up get out of here
get out of here
oh my god knuckles is behind me how dare you
knuckles
oh it's just knuckles where is he
go away knuckles get off the map
get off the map off the map
sideways no stop hitting that go sideways
where did you go
stop it you're scaring me
you're so small
where are you doing
get off the map okay
crazy if I still through the stream
when I need to wake up by the way
you get to talk about the Beagle Holder story
oh yes
so
I'm aware that Beagle and Givley came from
a hoarder home so a cat hoarder
home is when you let the cats
breed wildly
like a ridiculous amount
but Beagle
had such a hard time getting
used to like living with me
and I suspected
that he was also abused
which
unfortunately
I think I kind of confirmed it
because he was sitting in my lap
which he doesn't normally do
he's been getting so brave recently
but I went to scratch
my face like scratch my hair
and he
like he jumped off me so fast
he synced his claws into my thighs
to jump off of me
and like his eyes were massive
I mean absolutely
massive
and
but then when he realized I wasn't
doing anything
he did come back and sit on my leg
but
I think it kind of confirms to me
which is really fucking bad
I think he did get abused
and I thought that because he took
so long to adapt
to living with me
poor guy
literally
I'm glad that I have him though
like I'm so happy
like I said to you guys
that like I don't support munchkin breeds
or anything of that nature
and he's a mixed munchkin
but like I'm so glad
that I have him and he's mine
and he's safe and you know
he gets to meow at me and he gets to go in the garden
whenever he wants
and I'm actually
going to show you a project
I'm going to start shortly
I know DIY art
my fucking landlord
is a piece of
packer
basically
I got sent an email
from
the fucking company I'm renting
and they were like
you're such a good tenant
we would like to offer you another
12 months of rent
and I'm like
oh what's my reward
my reward is they're increasing my fucking rent
and then they sent me
they had the audacity
to send me documents
to in quotation mark
prove that I'm actually renting at
an insane discounted price
and it's like I can't remember
I didn't even fucking finish reading the email
I was so angry
that
I'm like you
you the rental market
that people are setting the price
why are you trying to pretend
genuinely
that the fucking market
has gone up
it's bloody you that fixes it
to make everything so astronomically expensive
and like I literally
just had an inspection I didn't say
but the other day I just had an inspection
and the actual landlord
that owns this place
he's like absolutely fine
he's had no issues in that
and I'm like
he never said anything
he said no I'm happy with everything and all that
and then I get an email
like two days later we're increasing your rent by the way
like
you approved that
I just can't
understand it sorry it makes me so aggravated
so anyway don't be surprised
when I fucking move out
and I'm like do you have to move
because I'm like so angry
if I think about it
landlords try not rent
congratulations 40 emblems
you can now play special mode
I don't know what on earth that was
bingo anyway
anyway that's me being absolutely
raging so I didn't be
surprised when
I genuinely was like oh my landlord
so nice he doesn't care
like I had to ask for
why are you here
like I asked
for permission
to hang up moving blankets
so that it's quiet
where are you cream
are you like way in the future
and
and he
like a text to them and explained
like oh I want to put out
put up soundproofing and all that because like
this is my type of job and whatever
and he was like yes yes
don't care do what you want and all that
and I was like oh my god amazing landlord
like someone who actually treats you like
a human that is living because there's so
many landlords that want you to
pay them rent
but not actually live at the premises
does that make sense when I say that
out loud because
it is short in behaviour
like they want to collect the rent
they want to accept you as rent in
but they don't actually want you to live like
it's a home like
you know this is someone's
fucking home because they don't obviously
have the fucking money to buy
a fucking house and this bloody
like oh my god
ah go sideways
I don't think I'm gonna
whoa
bing can I get another one bingo
yay
bingo bingo bingo
yes okay get the name get the name
yes
no but I know what you mean actually
so yeah exactly
sounds like main do you know how clogged
the public trash can be
um
like I just
it's the fucking greed of it because
I already pay an astronomical rate
sorry this is why I'm going back
to Scotland I'm not even kidding
like it's nice and all to conduct
business here but once the
once the business side of things is
ogre I'm going back to Scotland
fuck this
it was nice while it lasted truly
there are so many bad guys
landlords being
feeling under the ground girl
it's like impossible to feel at home
while renting literally because
so many landlords
are like oh my god
did you put
uh
sorry the camera angle is changing on my back
oh my god did you put a hole in the wall
to put up a picture of
a family member that you love in the
the space that you call your home at this
point oh my god
I am going to charge you
$100,000 in fees
because you have damaged
this property beyond repair
and it's like
I live here
like this is my home
I comprehend that I'm
renting from you and you physically own
the place but like
this is the only option
I have I live here
I'm not allowed to
make it a home
my last place they wouldn't renew the release
because the family needed some and then a year later
I see the whole town
and it's plans to build a big
yeah yeah literally
just
it's terrible
anyway maybe I should speak on some more
more a bit more positive
a bit more sonic heroes anyone
I can fix that
my last place
yeah like if I had a dollar for every time a
landlord was like you have damaged
my property beyond repair
I am taking this money out of your
deposit
oh man I fell off
I'd have three dollars which isn't
a lot but that's every time I've rented
so far and I know for a fact
when I move out of here
it's going to happen again
they're going to be like we need
eight billion dollars of your
deposit because you've trashed
this place beyond repair
you've done that and it's like
I'm literally a one
waman army with two fucking cats
please calm down
please explain what kind of damage I'm capable of
doing when all I do is sit on my PC
all day long
please
I just know
alright then
I literally
I sit around and I lick microphones
for eleven
what damage structural damage I have
caused because
it's not even plausible
this is baby mode and I'm still flying off the
map see this is why cream is superior
hold on
right do that
no cream aim
for the enemies
the aim ball when it comes to these enemies
is terrible
I have to live with three roomies now
to afford rent
literally
I don't get it
I don't
get
how nothing has been put in place
now I do
sorry to put my tinfoil hat on for a minute
sorry I love a good tinfoil hat moment
but it's because of the way the policies are made
and politicians can get paid off to keep these
things in force
they've been talking about for
fucking years now
they've been talking about
they're going to finally
regulate airbnb
so the market opens up because there's so many
properties taken off the market for airbnb
and they keep saying oh we're going to regulate it
we're going to regulate it
you've been saying that for years
just do it
how are people going to be motivated
to deal with their shitty jobs
if the lie
they've been told their whole life
if you work hard
you can own a place of yourself
that's not even possible
come on
if you want the people to work
they need to be motivated
if you care about the economy that much
give the people something to be motivated about
okay
because
100% there's no tinfoil hat needed for this
landlords
painting over the mold
oh my god
literally
what's the
where is the dice in here
it must be
oh no no no no no
how
please stop
no
come on I'm all the way back here
I'm losing in baby mode
I'm actually losing it
I'm about to put tinfoil hat on for real
I'm talking about pharmaceutical companies
nah I'm teasing you
caring about people in this economy
I'm not even kidding
if Vealer pops off
I'm starting a bloody landlord business
but here's the catch
it's not fucking predatory
there's the catch
fucking
Airbnb has a lot of renters that use hidden cameras
yes
oh my god there's so many complaints about it
I've seen so many articles
and videos and all of that
we need to pay an ink
exactly
you can't get fairer than that
okay please no more falling off the map
I can't handle it again
oh my god
the music is insane
it's so good
mummy house LLT
bruh
mark my fucking words
I'll come and fucking destroy the economy myself
if I have to
if this is the way I have to take down the high table
is just like produce astronomical
amounts of content a day
please do not think I don't have enough
spite in my body
to ascertain this
I will fucking do it
and you know I will
I will do it
because
mummy out here spitting truth
in fact like his bars on fire
I'm a starter
I know what my custom song is going to be
oh my god do it
I like stroney's spite
literally like
remember
oh no
don't move
a muscle
don't
move a muscle
don't move a muscle
we can tinfoil hat in a second
don't move a damn muscle
I think I'm safe oh my god
okay we're good
we're good
we did it oh my god we were like right at the end as well
we did it again
Scottish entrepreneur opens
new city with a new currency ink
on his loom
the modern day William Wallace
like you won't sort the economy
I'll do it myself because could you imagine the difference
you could make to one singular family
by being like
oh by the way your rent isn't astronomical
and
we're actually going to be fair with you
and we're not going to do inspections as well
because that's the privacy of your own home
could you imagine
the difference that I would make to one family
now imagine
if you could do it on a larger scale
imagine
where the people do not have to pay
artificially
inflated prices
and people can actually eat
how does society not want to progress to this
yes I know
I'm playing Sonic Heroes
and yes I know I have Sonic's hair on my head
and we are talking about the ethical
and unethical practices of society at large
okay I can be interested
in multiple topics at once
I know I'm mental but
you can't stop me okay
you can't stop me
because the rich corpus want all the money
what you mean those billion dollar industries
what
I mean
what would happen in theory
would I get slandered
I'd get slandered in the media
if I got too popular
oh no
crazy Scottish tries to fix the economy
I remember
right actually this is really big British lore
and
and either you'll know it
or you won't know it
there's this only fan
model her name's Rebecca Goodwin
or something and she got a
media post about her
because she with her
money she bought
houses
and she accepted people who were
like on benefits
and surprisingly the media did
cover it
and it's like sorry but
I
hashtag slags fixin the economy
I'm here for it please don't think
I'm not here I will do it
I'll fix that shit myself
this VTuber is a danger to our democracy
incredibly based
if you mysteriously disappear we know what happened
literally I promise I'm not depressed
I'm having a good time
having a good time
yeah she bought 10 properties
with her money
and
I did boys
I'll see if I can find the article
because I absolutely love it
I'll look back at it from time to time
because
I'm so here for it
it's I don't know if it's
obviously now don't get me wrong
I
was quite a challenge
I just absolutely adore it
I love like
I think like I've no exactly
hidden it or anything
that I was born like
no exactly with a silver spoon in my mouth
like I've never hidden it and you know I've done all the jobs on that
and it doesn't bother me
but I cannot tell you how many times
I knew someone
who fell on ridiculously hard times
because of something
out of their control like
I remember
like
one of the worst winters
we had in Scotland
the boiler broke for my family
it was
fucking peak winter
and we didn't have the money to like fix it
and I think
I don't know how many weeks
like I had to boil
a kettle
to wash
no this isn't a sap story this is me
literally telling you the origins of why I hate
capitalism
type thing
and
what am I doing
sorry this map gets confusing
and I used to have to boil
a kettle because we still had electricity
it's just the hot water wasn't working
and I have to like wash my hair in the sink
in that and wash my pits in the sink and all that
and I just remember
thinking like what is so fucked
here like what is genuinely so fucked
both my parents work
and we can't afford to get the fucking boiler fix
and I just remember like
the anger
and being like what is the problem
what is the problem why can't
and like oh my god don't even get me started
on those things where it's like
oh you're poor you shouldn't have
you shouldn't have nails
you shouldn't have makeup you shouldn't have
any luxuries in life
no motherfucker you're looking
at the wrong problem people
should be able to afford luxuries in life
people should be able to unwind
after work through their choice
of like um
what they want type thing
like oh my god
you're looking at the wrong problem
people should be able
to enjoy themselves
your villain
origins story literally
starting on full tinfoil
like sorry it started
at a young age that's all I'm saying
I got
what's the word I got radicalized
when I had to be like
so why can't we afford heat in
and when I have two
parents that are do or full
time workers
and it's like yeah sorry
sorry for being sorry for always
believing in the underdog
maybe it's because I was the underdog
maybe it was because I was that kid that needed
that fucking hand up
and I never got it I had to do it
all myself so excuse
me for thinking the best
in people you know
because
seriously I cannot tell you how many times
the answer is literally
someone just needs a simple help
a simple bit of help for real people are
like if you're poor you have to be sad
and downtrodden yeah literally
you must starve yourself
and eat one packet of ramen a day
because you put yourself
in that when it
comes to like people who are drug dependent
as well
I
could do a massive tinfoil
rant about like drug dependency
and people who experience
homelessness
and like the lack of empathy
and like
I don't please don't feel bad
if you genuinely have like the thought
process of like homeless people
deserve it they're drug addicted
they chose drugs over their family
do not feel bad if you genuinely
hold that belief right now at this very
point in time because
the truth of the matter is you have been
taught that it's their fault
you have been explained that it's their fault
and the reality of the situation
is please let me say the sentence
and please take a second to like really
internalize what I'm saying
so when people say you chose drugs
over your family
does that
not mean that the power
of drugs is so
so much stronger than the choice
of family of health of this
of clear conscious doesn't that show
you how powerful drug addiction
can be in someone
and instead of blame blame blame
blame blame blame blame can we
not take a step back and say you know
what there are people in this
world that have drug dependent
tendencies and that's
okay they need more help than the
average person that is the same
with people who are more prone to depression
they need more help than the average person
like
please don't worry if you do have the
perception of like I blame homeless people
for being homeless that is
okay that's understandable
you know please
allow me you know if you're willing
to hear me out please allow me to at least give
you like maybe just a little
bit of a different perspective because
like there is a statistic that says
like a ridiculous amount of
individuals in western society
are about one or two paychecks
away from not being able to
afford their current living situation
and they have nowhere to go which
is why I genuinely think
that generational households
are on the rise I'm so
sorry I would absolutely love
to live with my parents again
I would love to have
a big enough place that my grandparents
can also all of us can live together
and we can share
like the household duties
of like cleaning
of cooking just to get
that community back that formality
back I 100%
believe that generational households
should definitely
have an increase in rise
in western society
it's very common place in
where am I going
hahaha
society
yeah
mummy is the same
I just
want to see the goods
and I want to give the benefit of the doubt
and don't get me wrong of course
there is always a situation
an example that you could give and be like
well this person genuinely like
sabotages themselves
but the average person won't sabotage themselves
unless there's some
you know mental health issues
all this going on
like it's okay to give the benefit of the doubt
people really are just trying their best
and that's okay
can I even make that
I don't think so
wait what they have things
to do slight longer
whoopsies we live in a society
let's just say we're watching joker
I've still not seen joker
yeah it's like that so you already know I'm going to go off on one
no don't make me fall
you're so pretty
wait I can't go on the rail out there
going back to addiction
I get what you're saying but
why did you even try it in the first place
that's my problem
that's the thing people think
oh I'm not going to get addicted
or I don't need a vice
because I already have another one
so for example alcohol after work
is actually an addiction
it's a vice if you need alcohol
to de-stress
you have been sold
you know a societal lie
and that's perfectly okay
please don't feel bad if you drink
that's not what the thing is
what the problem is
is that work is so stressful
on the human body and the human mind
that you need a vice in order to
you know feel better
that's what the problem is
you're not the problem
and you know
for
pure pressure is very real as well
yeah that's also very true
social acceptance
it's perfectly normal to want to be accepted
by those who are around you
and feel the pressure of like
oh hopefully
they like me
all that kind of thing
I just don't like the taste of alcohol
unfortunately my city has organized groups
of homeless to panhandle for pentas
so that
actually got came to the
UK
I'm not, well I don't want to say too much
because a lot of racism attached to it
a lot of the time the exposure is
the first time to try drugs
it's related to how you were brought off as well
like trauma addicts in the family
yeah like hey it's hedgehog growth
exactly
yes especially
like your upbringing so like
my mum smokes and my dad drinks
and
I
because of the way I was exposed to it
I can't, I'm not interested
in
drinking I'm not interested in any
and smoking
like I have a drink when I'm having a carry on
with you lot
that's about it you know
oh no I need a yellow one
is it on the other side
I love my stuff a little bit
I need cream to be powered up
cream please
I need
cream to be so much stronger right now
she's just so good when she's leveled up
like honestly
I could do a massive educational stream
on it
and like I don't mind discussing
like some people
no what
sorry the laser got me
by the way
guys also girls on page
will set you back like one night
out of a bar just sit
wait wait wait wait wait
you're like advertising better than I should
don't be afraid to support the girls on patreon
it helps and
patreon is like a fantastic stable
income for them
because like youtube income kind of depends
on like how much they stream
or how much like a roleplay
sorry I'm messing up so badly right now
or like how much a roleplay might pop off on youtube
like
I'm actually gonna do a short
talking about doing ASMR
and like how much money you make just on youtube ads alone
no donations
no nothing I'm gonna discuss that
because when it's good
it's good but when it's
not when it's bad it's bad
but when it's just like average
it's like you can't even live off
with youtube income ads alone
it's very
in today's day and age
it is very
great I need to spam this
draft
I thought I could maybe
I'm gonna have to go a bit weir
okay that's fine
I was hoping to get
uh
can I use my ultimate
against that
I think
if I get him to come to me
I might use the ultimate when he
yeah this
should do it that's it
don't forget to use their codes for game
10% off yes the girls get to keep their
earnings from thingies
cause I'm sick of corporate greed
what what me strongy
sick of corporate greed 80-20 split
the girls get 100% of
marriage profits 100%
gamer subscode 100%
blue say what sick of greed
me no don't be
oh you're such a silly me flip
you're such a silly
silly
I didn't even level up
oh there's to come
well almost fell off the map
well
we've done it now
he's not getting away
he needs to come
to me there we go
it's like I'm gonna be the crap out of them
cause creams all leveled up there you go
creams super leveled up
we support vealers so strongy
can build her ethical landlord utopia
and give everyone a $10 house
legally real and true
before vealers did you used to do a lot of asmr
sure
sometimes
maybe
yes I did
I have always
thoroughly enjoyed asmr production
I enjoy
the sleep aid aspect
I also enjoy the
white noise aspect
a lot of people admit to me
like they just listen to me in the background
well
for the asmr in particular
they put it on in the background whilst they're playing games
or that kind of thing but streams are also really good for putting
on in the background if you're just
needing to do stuff if you have a wireless headset
and listen
like pop on a vealers stream of any of the girls
it doesn't have to be me it can be any of the girls
you can
unironically
be motivated to clean up cause
you're nice and distracted and all that kind of thing
I trust your judgement
aww thank you
that's a terrible idea
I'm too dumb for that kind of stuff
yes
I'd like to thank
even in my naivety
contributing to the dream
athernity thank you
let me erin it trust me
let me cook I have
tons of slans
they don't end so
basically my goal with vealour
vealour
um no
right okay let's try that again sorry
sorry getting a little thank you athernity again
just for the 20 sorry please
I beg your pardon
I think you guys should save the money
for the birthday bonus on
yes so um
I think it's very
safe to say that
I would like to stabilise the girl
I would like to stabilise
the girls that I have if that means
leaving out then that's literally
it's very lucky that azur's donathon
actually occurred
so early cause um
the youtubers' birthdays
aren't their atrial birthdays
oh my god insider knowledge
it's national goat days
azur's birthday
right let's not mess it up
gently right you're gonna reign
I'm going to use
you
and then
that one is the peach
okay
no no how
I'm on it
my immersion shattered
um but
I'm gonna try and get azur moved out
mercy wants to move out as well
so I'm gonna try and stabilise everyone so they're happy
where they're situated
and then if they
with like advice I can really hammer down
being like look this is what worked for me
this is successful for me
they like them flourish as well
they don't actually have to take my advice
okay well
third time's the charm
please make reign
thank you
and then
if and when gen 2 and 3 happens
it's my responsibility to
oh we did it we're safe
I feel responsible
for the girls that
would like to be on board
and even if I can make
a difference to their lives
like you know
mission complete
because as I said it's not about greed
it's not about
doing anything it's about
helping these girls that genuinely want
to be content creators
be full time content creators
and I can tell them
what I know and what I've learned
because you know I had to
personally I had to stumble about and figure it out
for myself
you know without that
stumbling about
oh we already
wait what
if I ever did a beach
I would stay in character so badly people think
I'm fully delusional
oh my god
the
the kefab
the keyfabe
we love viewer
kefabe
yes I
I feel responsible for the girls
and to do what the best I can
with what I can do you know
and I
I
I would normally admit I'm nervous
but I am nervous
further as Donathon
because it's to move
her out and I think
if she moved out she truly
is going to flourish
truly and wholeheartedly is going to flourish
please do not drop me on that vine
oh my goodness
I think
you're going to build an underwater
utopia
well we already got the farm in the plan
true believer mume
dealer to the moon and I'm glad
you did what you wanted
yes
it was very nerve wracking
in terms of
someone actually
clipped me recently
you can't just skip all the enemies here
that's a fair worry though
it comes from the right place but I think
it's going to be fine
I hope so
I hope so I hope so
I'm a nervous being
especially
because you know as I said
I feel responsible for all the girls
and you know
I was very caned
and you know explained to me
uh oh no
my things running out of charge
hold on
hold on my controller is running out of charge
I don't know how because I've not used it
oh wait no I played a game recently
that I had to use it
hold on hold on I'm taking the wire
I'm taking the wire
I only just started watching dealer a week ago
and I'm like oh good
as I said for anyone that's kind of lurking
I'm strong and I'm waving you
I have fantastic news
I have five other girls that I love
adore I want to kiss them on their little faces
I want them to spank my butt if we do an off galab
uh yes I'm forcing them to do that
I don't wait whoa why did that pause
don't do that to me
right I'm taking this out you get
this is going to be me if you hear a noise
that's me that's me
that's me
hold on I just need to
did that work
hold on
you never got food and water
I'm too busy talking about how much I love
my daughters okay am I not like to gush
about them that was me that was me that's my pc
making those noises it's not yours
um fill your belly
I'm subbed to every girl in the dealer and will do it in the future
Jen's
literally just even subscribing
and leaving a
hello
no what
no no no no don't do this
to me
no
wait why would you do that
why would you do that why would you go
mouse and keyboard are you serious
what the fuck is the mouse
and keyboard why is escape
attack
now hold on a minute
wait why would you do that
stop right no
stop you're scaring me hold on
stop
don't
please connect
escape is attack I kid you not that's me hitting
escape am I now my controller
won't connect
what have I done
quick question regarding
questions regarding donors
stream elements only or will
YouTube super chat membership
donation be considered
please ignore questions
must be the money
um no it's not
off topic you can talk about it you can
all of those talk about the other girls thank you math
for the super chat um
I think it has to be stream elements
only because if we
tally in what YouTube give we have to
add like 30% on top
and not to mention
we have access to the stream
elements funds almost instantly
YouTube take an entire
month like so
if you donate right now
to me like via
um super chat on YouTube
I don't get that money until the 25th
of next month
like YouTube hold on to it for a month
to process um
like it's very
I don't if we count it
super chat I don't know
I don't maybe I'll do my research
on recent donathons that went
on like MISMA had a recent donathon
that went really well I'm really I'm so
pleased for MISMA
um
big big
we kidnap this
no it's an evil
for all
YouTube get that one month
interest free loan
and what they say that oh sorry
sorry um
they say that
um YouTube actually doesn't make
money and I'm like
I mean I'm making money
so don't don't mind me the fuck
can you please
aim for that you know the balloon
that's right there thank you
cream
I called her cheese I was gonna call her cream cheese
cream cheese
I said I'm making a feature
cream cheese right now
the jungle
maps a bit crazy in terms of music
thank you
someone is making money off of that
video hosting is absurd
like yeah we had a few
website inquiries management told
me they were like for the devods that
need to get deleted can you host it
and I'm like
do you know how expensive that is
it's not that we don't
we'd rather just use like
all to see if the girls have to take something down
or whatever um
I did
request to limit
um
I did request to limit
the streams that need to be
taken down like in terms of like DMCA
or whatever and I didn't say
they're never allowed to do it again before someone
goes running taking out a contact no I didn't say never
try to write again I was saying
um
I was going to say wasn't there
a ball right here
just to try and limit it
because I did notice
a lot of
um content
was like being taken down and I'm like
I'm going please
please
looks like you don't stream when you're a full time streamer
video hosting is expensive that's why
YouTube has no competitors
well
that always kind of comes up
it's like oh why don't you make your own website
your own version it's like
I don't know if you guys know
Gibi ASMR
she's the in real life ASMR
um
and she
I think it
failed but not I don't mean
oh it failed terrible I mean like I think
it failed because hosting is so expensive
me wonder if I'm missing content
from you no no find any mentions
or links of this on any of your
Twitter no no no no no thank you
basically with you can ask questions
for free guys please
just if you think it's a good question you guys can repeat
if someone asks something that's good
um no
I'm not posted I'm not even
verified like I need to send in off
my ID and stuff so
um I've not done it so
please don't think you're missing out I'll let you know
woohoo
that's that band fan stream
no there's no content I can't find
no it will be on my alt
Twitter when
uh
her project
the biggest problem with other video hosting also is how people
will actually move over
yeah that as well is a massive
factor it's like
so a lot of people ask me
you know hold on
I can't see
excuse me
apparently it's
quick and me was verified in 20 minutes
and it's Shuby's background music
mysterious stranger
are there any hedgehogs in this game yeah me
okay let's go on cream
no leave me alone leave me alone don't touch me
don't touch me get off the map off the map
off the map
can you go for the ball thank you
you're gonna pay for this
amy is the hedgehog
oh is she
oh possible
isn't it true stuff
vectors in love with cream's mum
in the comics I didn't even know that
no
we
math thank you for the 10 gifted
I didn't know anything
but yes
um sorry if we're going back on
Azura's don't even thought unfortunately the stream
element is going to be the only
counter towards it
um just because
Azura can get access to that money
like we can you know obviously pass it on for
um and she can move out because she
was very kind and shared
with me uh the where she's
heading and uh
I just hope she loves it and everything
uh thank you again math for the
10 gifted memberships and congrats
to those who caught him
with their face
just on stream
elements
thanks for hanging
please rest well sleep well
and sweet dreams
I'll be in your dreams because I'll make them sweet
where am I going
I didn't expect that
sorry
cream is getting all the bonus hot points
I don't care she's just so pee
sorry mommy if it's off topic
when you go back to Scotland do your
time slot gonna change
um
I think I stream
like a really good time for Europe
and
I don't want to jinx it but
I think we are
probably
for gen 2 I'm going to kindly request
we'll see what works out
we'll see what works out for time slots
um
but I will
request
gen 2 to at least be
an hour
not at someone else's
start time they have to pick an hour whether that's
earlier before I would prefer
earlier so there's a bit of a
a sweep going on
cause I do tell the girls
like try and redirect into each other as much
as possible like that's why
literally I've been like pingas into streams
are 7 hours away
cause I'm like I just want the best for my
bloopers okay
ah fuck it
um veiler back to back
is 2pm
8pm Roma
yeah you stream at really good time
it's 8pm yeah literally night time
right before medivac I suppose during
and we're already at the end
see I love team rose it's so easy
sorry team rose is the best
I don't care when
we need more links in the
raid chain
yes I think
the
what's that
it's the end
the application
form
is gonna have a bit of a change
in it for gen 2 if we get there
link link um
yeah she be reading
ac after the collab the other day
was the first time she said yes
ac so mean ac when I do that
ASMR I'm taking ac slot because
she never gets redirected into
by gen 3
we're gonna have veiler 24-7 cable
that's what I'm here for baby
um are there gonna be any
mails no this is
a female
agent
and before anyone says
discrimination entertainment company
look up entertainment laws
if I post a job
saying I need to hire
a black male and then
a 4 year old white girl shows up
entertainment laws that's not who I need
casted for the role
so no I'm not gonna tolerate your bs
play me alone
sorry I got a bit passionate there
I cannot tell you
how much um
flak we got
for being like female only
I know you're not saying it sorry by the way
I know you're not saying it the person who typed that
please don't worry weflin I know you're just asking in general
um
uh we
got like so many inquiries
on the website being like why no mails
why no mails I demand
why no mails why why why why
I was like motherfucker
nothing is stopping you from making a male vtuber
agency how about you go fucking
make it instead of complaining
that
the one fucking dominated
industry of female content
creators
and you're complaining
go make your own vtuber
agency go get fucking
pregnant with four
designs in your stomach
and carry them for a year
don't come complaining to me
don't go complaining to me
as if I did the teen blast
and that comes out
um
uh
literally
anyway tell them how you really feel
Shawnee
yeah we did get a quite a few off topic
but it's still sonic tms channel
has released the first 10 episodes
sonic says that
sonic says the poops lure episode 2
thank you
tharia IVW
for the super chat you have sun locked me
with that super chat what have you communicated
does
the poops lure
caca
so no mails
to be a lure
I think the girl
I can't remember if someone asked about a po box
and I was like
if you're gonna do it
you need to put all these things in place
um
because it's so dangerous
and they were like
I didn't even know about that
and I'm like yep people literally put
trackers in peo boxes now
fucking things tell him
tell him so I preach to the choir
thank you
for the super the tip
the tip
um
yes
uh
there was a lot of
dumbass or feedback
but I can giggle at it
I think maybe it might annoy other people
but I know I sound like I'm being angry
or whatever about it
but I'm just genuinely giggling about it
because it's silly
a bit shilliness yeah
guaranteed the people asking a bitch
but no mails were grimer
you tell them how it is
uh yeah
it just
I think there was a lot of like
self deprecating
I don't know if that was the word
it was very some of them came across
very boo-hoo me
um in terms of like
I think one of them was like oh great
another vtuber agency that doesn't want mails
and it's like I'm not being funny
you know like how much time
blood sweat tears went into this
I'm gonna make the agency in my image
like I don't have experience
being a male creator
why the fuck would I fund
why would I have any faith in something
that I have no experience in
like if you really want to get into
the nitty gritty of like
I would never if I did not have
experience I would never have even
concepted anything
but it's based on
like what I know
things that can be done like as I said
the clipping program is up right now
um I think
uh
like that's like another way
to promote the girls and like the girls
all have their tiktoks running we have shorts
on the way constantly cause shorts
are a good way to grow
just like
you're leveraging
earned wisdom talk your talk
yeah sorry I could go on a ramble about it
in like a 8.8 page
essay but not worth it
with um
a ritual hazing
wait we're ritual hazing
let's
get to work
I do like the speed characters
cause like the enemies just go flying off the map
mummies peel box just full of
reflux boxers in shorts
I wanted to
ask for hoodies but then
I did actually see a report
and no I was not a report sorry
like a post and this
uh content creator was like
I literally have just
found an air tracker in my stuff
and I was like well let's
not happening with me
uh no chance
um
there's one way I can get around it
but
I want to like you know how those
like people that like opening packages for the first
time on stream
type thing like that's where the fun
is it's like oh my god super surprise
reaction to this so if I already
had gone through the packages at a safe
location it's just not the same like it's
not what it's not what the
base of the content would be about you know
we did do it we're so good
please scream
okay we got level 3
mr. big
if I could get level 2
cream I'd be rather happy
with that
wait
can't send
boxers to mom because of them
sticking to a D magnetizer
well like I started doing
research on it because I like that
fun stuff but
I just it just has to be
safety first you know and
I just
obviously I don't want no trouble
I just want to enjoy myself and have fun
and sometimes
you know you got
you got to do what's safe for you
I'm gonna cough in a minute I need to get
I need to get a cola after this one my throat is like
oh excuse you
sorry sorry no get away
maybe instead of a live stream you could do a video version
no I'm just high by the way
safety first
yeah
country specific seeds
oh my god
I don't know if you heard but I like
the level you cream mumble
wait what did I said something about cream
broly legend thank you for the tip
no cola
I'm not allowed wait
how about I'll make you a deal
I'll make a sandwich
I'll make a tea a cola and a water
you said level 2 cream
but I like level you cream
oh my god that's a
I'll wait until you get to the
you can also get voile mail
x-rays
I know the x-ray though
I'm gonna cough
the dehydration is getting me
refunds
cream can we
man I feel
okay let's be super safe
okay let's
let's get broyed
into
the level
I don't know what that but it's probably got a money in it
drink some water
I'm going I'm going
team roost starts
at the first blue ship
yes team roost
easy peasy landing squeezy
the levels are so short
as well
that was lucky
literally
it's so good
it's so quick you're not like
cutting about doing too much
that's why I'm worried about team dark
you guys were saying the levels are like hell along
and there's tons of enemies
I think
the way team dark will be is that you have to
defeat the enemies in the vicinity before you can progress
which
you know it isn't like a major problem
but it is going to take longer than
I first suspected
but then if we finish this
we literally only have
one more team to do
I think you guys reassured
me and said that if I die
like if I run out of lives in Sonic
I actually don't like
we need to defeat him
what about team light
there is no team light
you're teasing me there's no team light
drink some water
I will I will I will
it's cause we're almost finished team rose I'm like
I can finish team rose cause it'll take me
how did I not hit any of them
I have three hit mark
like three bodies of hit marker
the game's like no you've no
yes I am
sorry flying type is the best in this game
I don't care what anyone says it keeps you safe
from falling off the map
what
the game literally did that
all by itself
did you see like the all way
on the rail that was by itself
I wasn't telling it to do that
God
what about the secret eggman
stop I don't know what it is
my goal was just 100%
today
God I want Sonic to death
I sneered on my face
I get a long time you'll see
ha bow thank you bow
wait I already did it
in the other stream
wait a minute
I already sat on Gura
in the other stream
I actually can't wait for the seed
education stream where you show us these
I'm gonna get
more so originally I was like
I'm not allowed to buy seeds from the supermarket
and just scavenge them
but I've been getting like
vegetables which obviously come
with seeds and so does fruit
it comes with seeds naturally and I'm like
ugh you know what
why am I being silly doing this to myself
when I genuinely have like a fascination about it
like why am I trying to
sweat a seed collection hobby
it's literally a hobby
I'm gonna make people quit because of
sweats like me
other fellow seed enjoyers
are gonna quit because I'm not playing again
I'm not doing it with sweats like this around
oh I never saw that sorry
blind sorry blind again
stop jeez get in my face
yeah
it's just kicking him
literally I'm like why am I
trying hard and why am I playing hard
mode on a hobby like this is my own hobby
I'm allowed to do what I want
not be a silly sausage
mama just to warn you
most of the bonus missions
are much harder than any of the chaos emerald
stages
the is the chaos emerald
stages the balloon missions
oh my god I'm currently playing through obs right now
that was a terrible idea
wait how did I get past the lasers
I don't get past the lasers this is a
secret mission
wait oh it's a mr. big thing
mommy do them with team roses a lot easier
I'll come back I'll come back okay I just want
100% everyone's hello
can you become mr. big
please become mr. big
mr. big I need mr. big
the game won't let me turn into mr. big
I got a land I can't
I'm trying to shove myself on this but mr.
big hit am I stuck no way
come on
you're almost there
my wingtis
my wingtis is too big
oh
you know when you make things harder for yourself then it has to be
I'm a emerald
no stop it
I'm losing all my coins
you're taking all my lucky charms
sorry I don't know why I said that please
please ignore me
huh
oh I love cream when she's leveled up
I love cream
yes I do
she's the best in this game yes she is
I literally feel like what three minutes to do that level
in fact
we pay attention to you harder
you will not ignore me
she had an Irish moment
and today we are gathered here
for the gameplay of strongy cuddle
it's absolutely shite
but it doesn't matter because
oh you found that tough
did you darlin I'll tell you what's tough
I can't really do an Irish accent for very long
thank you tiny spiny for your super chat
I hope that I've been saying everyone's
we're literally on the last mission
we're so good
we're so good at
oh I almost fell off man
you want an Irish role play now
oh that's a good refling
oh that's a good boy yes you are a good boy aren't you
you make mummy very proud
don't you
good boy
where am I going
am I going down
I'm yelling timber
wait actually
new Scottish clip acquired
I'm going to see
if someone clipped when I was mucking about
like with my German Scottish accent
wait what
hello hi
is that one of these
have I missed a something as well
oh I heard it I heard it
something doing I heard it where's the
doing
here's the doing I can't find it
I leave it drunk Irish woman
hits on you at the pub
she says oh I want to do
cougar Irish woman though
I want to do cougar Irish woman
oh there you are
aren't you awfully young looking
what are you doing around these parts
oh you can legally drink can you
you're quite the looker aren't you
you must have all the girls fancy in you
what's that
oh you don't have a beaut to call your own
up to home
what kind of wealth are there
oh my Pintas
I hate these guys
it's my Pintas
oh what's wrong you never had a
woman take a fancy to you
well don't be shy
I can look after you
you want to find out
see what I'm gonna do
I'll tell you what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna excuse myself
and go
go to the ladies
I'm losing the accent
I'm gonna go
I'm gonna excuse myself
and I'll take myself to the ladies room
and you're gonna follow me in
follow me in in five minutes time
and don't make it obvious
for what happens
I've tried so hard to maintain it
rather
rather awkward
now do a regular British accent
pretend my mother is proud of me for once
I mean can we have a Holy Trinity
oh there
thank you for the super chat
what part of England
I can do scouts
why are you trying
hold on hold on let me try and
what's going on
wait what the fuck
I can normally do an English accent
so fucking easy
who do I mimic
I need a voice to mimic
pick a person that I know to mimic
Yorkshire
just looking for me to at least
to
no no I'm up to no I'm just playing game
yep
lion tit witch and tit world rob
just playing game yep sonic heroes
game from childhood
tit child
ok maybe my English accents are a bit rough
ok
can I do
Welsh
Mr Frodo
I'm just your gardener
alright my loves have you been looking
after yourselves I hope so
what's up
hello everyone
my name is sonic
I'm playing
you put them all under it
well Irish isn't
British but you know
better than any American I've ever
tried to do
I Yorkshire so that's ok
I can't carry it
I can't carry it but I can
carry you
come on Mr Frodo
think of the Shire
those men could have turned back at any time
but they didn't
they had something worth fighting for
now did Dr Evil from Austin Powers
oh no I've not watched Austin Powers
how is it
chavgirls suggests you
what's going on then Dr Rigman
he can't
lord of the reef
just to let you know
it's Zarya with a J not an I
Zarya
wait really
we need to watch Austin Powers
yeah I've not seen it
we can watch it together
remember that time I played this
as a child and I always got stuck
here and I could never fight him
I don't know what the problem was
seriously what was the problem
all I had to do was move a little
to the left what was the problem
was I so uncoordinated
as a child I think
so
cause there's literally
no way in heck this is difficult
I don't know what the problem was
I'm just gonna spank him in the chest
I must stay up here
where it's safe cause the missiles
can't hit me
groovy babies
the tent scene
or is there a scene that's going to make me crack up
the game says Zarya
but it's the rumours version of the name
Zarya
little strong head of mummy
was
Tiz maxing when she was so young
real and true
did I tell you about how I got
tested for here and then my mum never
investigated any further
and why I wasn't paying attention to anything
I can't remember
oh if I can reach him
I can't reach him
unless
no you're aiming for the wrong things guys
it's a dream
can I get
a level 3
is he gonna come
no
I don't know what he's doing
okay he's fine we've got it
we've got it
stop going for the miss
go for him right in front of us
go
I'm not gonna spoil but yeah there's a tent scene
you got Tiz and Tiz and didn't have a fault
so what happened
was I wasn't
listening to anything
so my mum got my hearing
tested and they passed
it and they said no I can hear
and she just never went a step further
it's not her fault
or anything she didn't know any better
but basically I just
wasn't listening to anything
but that was me choosing
not to listen
because I wasn't interested
froggy
we got froggy
he's so cute
Sonic
alright go go make dinner
this is such a beautiful song
I love it
eat the takima
oh my god you've seen that meme
I went strong eat chase after
it was the way Amy chases after Sonic
real and true
yeah team rose is super easy
it was
it was the only thing I used to
replay over and over playing Sonic heroes
but I never finished the ending
because I couldn't finish that boss
as a child
it was too hard
I must have had very poor coordination
mmm
what a lovely singing voice
as well
the producers of this game got arrested
for tax fraud
like they worked on the game they deserve a burpenny
there's a Scottish villain in Austin Powers
that you're gonna love
is that the get in my bailey meme
I know about the get in my bailey meme
I think to replay team chaos
really
okay well I quickly
excused myself
to go make a sandwich and get some liquids
can we agree
that we all need a stretch
fake stretch
I
stretch
right okay
I am gonna write everyone break time
it's time to tinkle it's time to stand up
and get that blood flowing
okay we need to
put those back flow
valves to work
okay and your veins
okay and your veins only team
hit the news
joining him with the news
right I'm gonna go for a quick tank up
I'm gonna make a cup of tea and I'm also gonna toast some bread
so give me a second alright
it'll be a hot second
hopefully the theme music
okay I'll be a beard back
make sure you stretch
I forgot my cup like a dumb ass
I